This is Jocko podcast number 65 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
The things they carried were largely determined by necessity among the
necessities or near necessities where 30 [inaudible] can openers,
pocket knives,
he tabs,
wrist watches,
dog tags,
mosquito repellent,
chewing gum,
candy,
cigarettes,
salt tablets,
packets of Koolaid,
lighters,
matches,
sewing kits,
military payment certificates,
c rations and two or three canteens of water.
Together.
These items weighed between 12 and 18 pounds depending on a man's habits or rate
of metabolism.
Henry Dobbins,
who was a big man,
carried extra rations.
He was especially fond of canned peaches in heavy syrup over poundcake.
Dave Jensen who practiced field hygiene,
carried a toothbrush,
dental floss,
and several hotels sized bars of soap.
He'd stolen on rnr in Sydney,
Australia.
Ted lavender,
who is scared carried tranquilizers until he was shot in the head outside the
village of fate.
K in mid April
by necessity and because it was sop,
they all carried steel helmets that weighed five pounds,
including the liner and camouflage cover.
They carried the standard fatigue,
jackets and trousers.
Very few carried underwear on their feet.
They carried jungle boots 2.1 pounds and Dave Jensen carried three pairs of
socks and a can of doctor Scholls foot powder as a precaution against trench
foot
until he was shot.
Ted lavender carried six or seven ounces of premium dope,
which for him was a necessity.
Mitchell Sanders,
the RTO carried condoms.
Norman [inaudible] carried a diary rat.
Kylie carried comic books Kiowa.
A devout Baptist carried an illustrated new testament that had been presented to
him by his father who taught Sunday school in Oklahoma City,
Oklahoma
as a hedge against bad times.
However,
Kai will also carried his grandmother's trust,
distrust of the white man
and his grandfather's old hunting hatchet.
Necessity dictated because the land was mined in booby trap.
There was sop for each man to carry a steel centered nylon covered flak,
which weighed 6.7 pounds,
but which on hot days seemed much heavier
because you could die so quickly.
Each man carried at least one large compress bandage,
usually in the helmet band for easy access
because the nights were cold and because the monsoons were wet.
Each curator,
green plastic Poncho that could be used as a rain coat or ground sheet or
makeshift tent with it's quilted liner.
The poncho weighed almost two pounds,
but it was worth every ounce in April.
For instance,
when Ted lavender was shot,
they used his Poncho to wrap him up than to carry him across the patty than to
lift him onto the chopper that took him away.
Okay.
And that excerpt
is from a book called the things they carried by Tim O'brien in the book is
about the Vietnam War and it's actually a blend of nonfiction and fiction
and part of that blend
comes from what he actually experienced for real as a soldier in Vietnam in
third platoon,
Alpha company,
Fifth Battalion,
46th Infantry Regiment.
Incidentally,
he was in the same division and the same area of operations where the mee Lai
massacre took place.
And then that reality is intermingled with his thoughts and ideas and stories
that put together a unique perspective.
Okay.
On War.
But the book is considered fiction and I don't like to dig too deep on fictional
books so I'm not going to go too deep on this one,
but I was having a little conversation with my brother Leif Babin
with whom I wrote a little book called extreme ownership and Lafe and I were
talking about the things that we carried
and tonight we have the good fortune of having my brother Leif Babin here with
us again today and I figured a good way to begin talking about what we carried
was to kind of compare and contrast what we did carry with what men like Tim
O'brien carried in Vietnam.
Leif Babin,
my brother,
welcome to the show for the third time.
Thanks for having me on.
Good to be back on again.
And for those of you that don't know who leaf is,
if you haven't been listening or you,
this is if this is basically the first time you've ever listened to this podcast
for some reason is because if you're not going to go life is life was in the
seal teams with me.
We were in the battle of Mati together and when we both got out of the military,
I retired in late life,
got out and we ended up working together.
We have a little business called echelon front where we work with companies and
teach leadership and management.
And we wrote a little book like I just said,
called extreme ownership.
And after actually if you want to know about life,
well you can read extreme ownership,
you can listen to podcast number 11 and podcast number 34 leaf was the first
guest and here he is back again.
So
Leif Babin,
what did you carry?
Talk to me about that compared to what these guys in Vietnam carried.
I mean obviously there's a lot of similarities and there's a lot of differences
too.
What do you think?
Definitely.
I mean it brings back so many memories just thinking about all the stuff that we
carried and uh,
with us and uh,
and the,
the burden of the,
you know,
just the heavy,
we used to joke about stuff,
body armor back,
you know,
in the body armor is just biting into your traps after you've had it on for
hours and hours of the helmets,
just the vice down on your head.
And obviously we had to train and prepare so that we,
we could,
we could prepare to have loose things off for hours and hours on end and be able
to deal with that.
And um,
in fact,
I remember you being the only guy in the universe that actually liked a certain
type of headset that we were using because it actually crushed down on your
skull and it was like,
bring it good.
Everyone else is complaining about it and you're like,
you're like,
I actually like this.
Ah,
that thing hurt my head.
I would never have admitted it back then.
But yeah,
it hurt bad.
It would squeeze your head in that awkward way and it was bad.
That was a,
that was a gnarly old headset but
a lot heavier because the body armor where we're at,
how much did,
how much did our body or on her way,
and it was like seven pounds of plate and you've got a front back plate and then
you've got the nine mil body armor and you're that that right there is heavy.
And then the funny thing is we were able to make our weapons a little bit
lighter over time,
but then we've decked him all out with lasers and optics and everything.
So the weapons,
I bet you are,
our weapons were actually heavier.
Definitely.
And then like for me,
um,
you know,
we,
we had trained to carry those little 10 inch barreled.
Uh,
we have an m four for the tenants,
Brill,
which we use for a close quarters combat you house clearance and,
and uh,
as you know,
that was like the primary weapon and we get to robotic.
I was like,
Hey,
I got to carry my 14 hits bureau,
which is longer and it's got an m two o three grenade launcher on it.
So you've got a 40 millimeter grenade and that's what becomes,
comes a lot heavier.
A based on that.
I just,
I needed that to be able to throw some 40 Mike Mike down.
Now,
one of the things that I know was,
uh,
mean we all learned a lot in combat and actually Andy Stumpf was just on and,
and I know you're friends with him too,
but we were talking about the learning curve of how quickly you learn things and
I know you,
you learn some pretty,
pretty solid and,
and rough lessons out of the gate going on to big patrols.
Right,
right,
right.
When we got there.
And just specifically about what you carried.
Absolutely.
I mean,
we had,
you know,
we had to focus so much on doing a roll up of salt.
We're loading up in vehicles so you're not,
you don't have to carry much on your person because a,
we're,
we're trying to,
to,
to drive up and vehicles and so we get to Ramadi and of course we'd done our
patrols out of a desert,
done that,
that training and prepared for that.
But we think we're good on Iraq and we're going to,
we're going to drive and vehicles and we get to Ramadi.
And these ideas are so dangerous and killing people.
So what do you do?
You get out of the vehicle and you patrol,
which means if you're going into an area and you got to carry everything on your
back and you've got to carry enough water and all the stuff you've got to have
for the next 24,
even 48 hours,
it's a lot of stuff.
And one of the,
the first patrols,
uh,
I've done a few patrols on kind of the outskirts of town,
you know,
but,
but that city center where it was al Qaeda control battlespace and US troops
were dying,
uh,
an almost everyday and this horrible violent place.
We've been on the ground for a,
I think a couple of weeks,
uh,
in and,
and we were teaming up with a marine unit from three,
eight Marines,
third battalion,
Eighth Marines,
Outstanding Group of warriors who've been on the ground for a month or two prior
to us getting there.
And they were,
these guys were in the thick of the fight and uh,
they were,
they had adjusted their tactics and learned how to go out there and,
and uh,
and conduct these patrols as we were teaming up with them to go into an area
called firecracker circle as firecracker is in,
hey,
this is a happy place with 4th of July or firecrackers and massive bombs as in
there's a 400 pound explosive in the road that's going to blow your vehicle a
hundred feet in the air and kill everybody there.
That was that area of firecracker.
They did not,
as a matter of fact,
when we,
even later than this,
when you were looking at doing operations in there,
and I remember sitting there with the Marines going,
hey,
what's the QRF situation?
Who can come in and get us?
And they were like,
hey look,
we're not coming in there with vehicles unless they're like,
hey,
if it's an absolute worst case scenario and you got to get somebody Kaz of act
immediately,
but if you get a guy get shot in the leg and you can stop the bleeding,
you're going to wait until nighttime.
They were adamant about not going in there because it was so bad.
I mean,
they patrolled in there all the time,
which you're about to talk about,
but nobody wanted to bring vehicles up in those streets.
And actually part of that reason is because just before we got there,
they took a massive I,
the Marine Corps took a massive idea and I think the last four or five marines
in one shot just juiced to total travesty.
That was right as we were arriving.
We hearing the stories about that and read the reports on it and a horrible,
horrible deal.
But that was it.
That was a great tactic that we learned from the Marines,
which is listen to the bad guys.
They want to blow you up in the streets.
They're going to try to target your vehicles,
they're going to try to ambush you.
So when you're in a building and a sniper,
Overwatch position and you're behind concrete walls,
like stay in that position,
stay in that position,
unless you have an urgent surgical casually,
you've got to get out right now or you gotta be overrun only an extreme
situation.
So we're not going to call in the QRF cause they're gonna blow up the vehicles
and that's what they want you to do.
And they taught us some of those things that were,
uh,
that helped keep our guys alive and certainly helped us,
perfect.
Our,
our,
uh,
our tactics,
techniques and procedures to be able to,
to go deep into those areas and,
and uh,
and do some real damage to the enemy and most of the time bring our Gesso.
So,
so speaking of going deep,
how deep did you have to dig on that first patrol out with three?
So we're going into this area.
We just,
you know,
these marines are just lost guys in and we were going in with Lima Company,
Outstanding Group of Warriors.
Uh,
and,
and you know,
we were excited to go in and work with them.
So I've got a,
you know,
we got to about a squad of,
uh,
of seals going in.
We've got some Iraqi soldiers and we're going to team up and we're going to put
in some mutually supporting sniper,
Overwatch positions,
uh,
and remain in,
through,
we'd go in at nighttime,
we'd remained through the day and we come out the next night.
So I'm like,
Hey,
I'm going in there.
We may be in there for 24 hours.
It could even be longer if we get delayed.
And you know what,
this is a bad area and nobody can come,
come get us out.
So I'm load now for world war three and you know,
my first time going to these areas,
I mean,
I'm packing hand grenades and extra mags and you know,
our typical load out was two hand grenades.
And I think I added a,
I added like three or five extra Hagar mates that I was bringing in.
So I put that in my bag.
I'm bringing,
I've got eggs,
you know,
my typical Lexi laughing about this because we've done a lot talk about world
war one and they had grenade battles like trench to trench grenade battles.
And I don't even think if I was going into our grenade battle where that was my
primary weapon,
I would have seven grenades.
Like life was carried right into Ramadi bridge.
It's awesome.
So I'm getting,
I'm getting ready,
I'm getting ready to get some.
And uh,
you know,
I'm,
I'm thinking metaphor.
We've were getting overrun and we're loading up on it.
So it's like one more thing,
one more thing,
you know,
extra mag here,
extra mag there.
So,
you know,
I've got,
I've got those extra hand grenades,
I've got the extra uh,
smoke grenades.
I've got,
uh,
you know,
I've got flash bang grenades.
I've got,
you know,
four or five extra magazines in addition to like the seven magazines.
Each of these are 30 round magazines.
Be Curious.
I that a my class at least it sounds crazy amount of.
And then of course I've got my,
I'm carrying my 40 Mike,
Mike,
right?
So I've got 40 millimeter grenades as well and a,
and I was typically,
you know,
I'm,
I'm loading that out.
So,
so I've got a bandolier of 12 of those things.
I think I had six more on me,
um,
in,
in a pouch on my waist.
So literally,
I mean,
I'm rolling in like John Jay Rambo style ready to get some so that this
seriously,
you know,
as I'm sitting here thinking that must've been a hundred pounds worth of gear
with your body armor,
all those grenades,
smoke grenades,
40 Mike,
Mike,
you must have had it at least close to 100 pounds I think.
I think easy because then you tack on water,
you know,
that was the biggest limiting factor for us.
I mean,
you know,
and you've got the,
the summertime heat over there.
It's just,
just unbearable.
You know,
may hit 115 hundred 20 degrees and uh,
so we're here we are,
remain over day.
You're not gonna drink the water out of the Faucet,
you know,
unless you want to be,
unless you want to be visiting the,
making some frequent head gauze and having some,
some,
uh,
dysentery for the next,
next few days.
Uh,
and what that's going to bring you.
So,
um,
so you got to get to carry that water in.
You know,
we carry these leader and a half bottles that they had.
I think I had probably 10 or 12 of those models too.
So I'm like,
I don't want to run out of water so I can give you a bunch more,
you know,
that even thought I need it.
So ridiculous amount of weight that I'm cured.
And so we load it up.
I mean I'm,
I'm having a hard time even just,
you know,
picking this bag up.
But it in,
so we loaded when our vehicles,
we drive,
we meet up with the marines,
we're loading up into their big seven ton trucks that they took in and they put
the troops in the back,
these huge vehicles and that that was,
they would kind of drive you on the outskirts of the batteries on roads had
cleared.
Um,
and hopefully you are protected and you know,
in those,
in those vehicles from the armor.
Then we unload,
we loaded unloaded from the vehicles once we got to a point.
And just so everyone knows these are like mad max scenario vehicles that,
that,
that people,
military guys had had put steel on the sides,
you know,
half inch steel on the side to protect from rounds with sandbags on the floor.
You know,
just put sandbags all over the floor.
So it's not like when,
when,
when he's talking about an armored vehicle,
don't think of a tank or,
or a Bradley fighting vehicle.
He's talking about a mad max scenario.
Big giant seven ton truck.
It looks like a construction truck basically,
but it's got big steel walls on it and now they put sandbags on the Florida
prevent from ids and that's going to war in the fun way straight,
straight out of the road warrior.
Definitely.
Um,
and so we get dropped off from those,
those vehicles and of course we're kitting up.
And you know,
as soon as I'm putting this thing on,
I'm like,
man,
I'm Karen,
I can't wait to drink this water.
You know,
uh,
I can't wait to try to shoot some of these rounds,
you know,
get,
get rid of some of this way.
Cause I realized like it's,
it's crazy.
It's a crazy man.
Of course you're like,
you know,
you don't want to run a Ammo,
but she also,
you know,
you,
you can't,
if you can't move then it,
the more dangerous.
So we started to patrol and we're moving in the area and uh,
and,
and the Marines who,
who'd spent time on the ground,
I was,
I talked about,
I mean their,
their method of patrol because there were a lot of enemies,
snipers out there.
And even though it's nighttime,
you know there's still some street lights and things like that.
So then method of patrol is two man shooter,
Paris and there those guys got each other's backs.
You got two guys covering two different directions and they're holding on a on a
on a street corner and,
and then they're waiting for the next a shooter pair that's up to the next block
from them and they sprint all out mad dash sprint as fast as you can go as fast
as you can run from one corner to the next corner,
maybe 100 million are covering sprint as exactly here.
And some of those blocks,
maybe it's 50 hours,
some moments a hundred yards.
But you know,
and this is how they patrol into the city.
So it's,
it is your,
your sprint hold sprint whole sprint hole and you know,
a few blocks of going into that and we're kind of moving around the city and
misdirection is like,
man,
I am smoked,
I'm having a hard time keeping up and just my hats,
these,
these young marines that are just getting after it,
carrying heavy,
heavy equipment and gear and the,
the radio men and the gack here in his,
you know,
his 40 Mike,
Mike,
and they're of course they're carrying the two,
uh,
two 40 bravo machine gun,
which is a,
uh,
a belt finishing it.
That was much heavier than what,
what uh,
are you ma mark 48 slide are machine guns were,
uh,
for,
for our meeting machine guns.
But,
um,
those guys were just awesome.
Just awesome trying to,
you know,
trying to work with them.
But I am,
I am having one hell of a time trying to keep up with these guys.
So what does that do to your,
uh,
what's that do to your leadership capability?
Wouldn't here?
Well,
here I'm,
I'm tired here.
I'm supposed to be in charge of this thing.
So I'm in charge of this.
I'm in charge of my guys,
you know,
we've got a squad of eight of our guys,
eight seals and,
and uh,
you know,
does and Iraqi soldiers.
So,
and I'm supposed to be in charge.
I'm supposed to be thinking about the bigger picture and be able to detach and
all the things that we talk about sitting back and thinking about,
you know,
uh,
what's going on,
you know,
a half mile up the road and in making,
uh,
radio calls back to the tactical operations center and talking to you and
telling you where we are and what's going on.
And I can't,
I'm,
I'm focused at this point on putting one foot in front of the other,
just head down,
one foot in front of the other and just try to keep up,
you know.
And here I am,
the guy just having a hard time keeping up.
And it was,
it was humbling,
humbling experience for me.
Here I am,
uh,
a seal,
a team guy thinking I'm in shape and uh,
you know,
and I'm in an area where,
I'm not a climatize to this kind of brutal heat.
Even at nighttime it's 95 degrees outside,
you know,
and there's no wind,
no wind,
no wind.
And you think,
oh,
it's a dry heat in the desert.
No,
the river's like,
you know,
just,
it's not a dry yeah,
right.
Yeah.
We were half,
you know,
half a mile off the river,
so it's,
it's,
it's humid along along the river.
So,
uh,
it was,
it was horrible and I was realizing like this,
I got my ass kicked.
I mean,
it was by the time we got back from that,
it was,
I knew I was going into a heavy,
like heat exhaust,
like I was,
I was hitting the like the heat exhaustion point.
Whereas like this is rough.
This is rough.
And that's the thing that's scary about heat exhaustion scenarios is it's like a
cliff you're walking off of.
And when you're getting close to the cliff and when you go off of it,
it's not like you say,
okay,
let me get a sip of water.
No,
you're in big trouble.
You got guys carrying you now cause you,
you know,
if you get heat stroke or heat exhaustion,
it's own bad,
bad situation and it doesn't matter how tough you are,
you're not going to be able to power through that.
Right.
Physically.
Uh,
it,
and so that's what,
you know,
that's a nightmare scenario for me that here I am the leader and yet if I can't
keep up with someone has to carry me.
Right.
That was a,
that was just going to be a horrific disaster.
So we went to that operation.
We were out there for a,
you know,
uh,
remained throughout the course of the,
the day daylight we got shot at,
we shot it some bad guys.
And uh,
and then we came out,
you know,
the next night and uh,
I got back from that.
I was like aggressively returning fire or some of those rounds.
We definitely,
Chris unfortunately didn't get a chance to throw any of the hand grenades,
which was a real bummer.
Um,
but,
uh,
yeah,
I mean it was,
it was a real rude awakening for me,
just being humbled by that experience to come back and think I'm carrying way
too much stuff.
I can't,
you know,
it's,
sure I don't want to run out of Ammo,
you know,
and,
but,
but how much more dangerous is it for me to be carrying so much stuff that I
can't even keep up on a patrol.
I can't move fast when I need to.
And if bad guy starts shooting at us,
I can't get my guys off the street,
you know,
or I can't move,
run across the street or run up the stairs and,
and so I recognized right away like,
I've got to,
I got a pair of this down and I got to carry just the essential stuff and maybe
a couple of contingency plans.
Like maybe I got one extra grenade,
my in my backpack.
Um,
and maybe I don't even need that,
you know?
Um,
what do I really absolutely need?
You know,
don't want to run out of water out there.
So maybe I got one extra bottle.
Don't need for,
you know,
um,
with me.
And,
and that enabled me to,
to recognize that I've got to carry only the essential stuff cause you can
absolutely get overwhelmed.
Um,
and part of that too,
if you're,
you know,
we were training,
we trained at La land warfare at the time,
you know,
what was the attitude was we do land warfare in the seal teams.
So we don't,
we don't wear a helmet,
body armor for land warfare.
So we'll go out and patrol across the desert and do that stuff.
We wear a helmet,
body armor when we do CQC,
close quarters combat in the,
in the kill house.
And you know,
here we are in an urban environment like,
God,
I've got to be able to do both.
I'm foot patrolling and then we're clearing houses.
Yeah.
So got to have that stuff.
Uh,
and,
and you just recognize how you just cannot carry all that stuff with you.
So that was the rude awakening for me.
And the other piece of that was physical training.
You know,
here I was thinking I'm in shape,
I'm a team guy,
you know,
uh,
we train hard,
we pushed the envelope and yet I am not in good enough shape to be able to,
to perform at the level I need to in this kind of heat,
in this kind of environment.
You know,
and after that,
you know,
you would see now it was a lesson,
not just me learn,
but I,
I saw so many reasons.
It's your rosary,
you showed up if you showed up at like noon,
uh,
if the heat of the day you'd see guys out doing tire flips,
doing,
do you know,
sprints running,
uh,
working out to get a climatized to be ready for those,
those worst case scenarios.
And we recognize that.
We thought we were good and we had to step it up to two uneven.
I actually took one of those workouts and I would do that at,
at victory and Mariana training fighters book the workout was,
it was uh,
uh,
a dummy carry cause we had a big old heavy bag.
So it was a dummy carry,
carry it down and back,
Sprint as hard as you can.
Then grab the tire.
It was a tire pull down and back and then a sprint down and back.
And what that was stimulating it was like,
okay,
you might have to pick up a guy and carry him down or carry them somewhere.
Then you also might have to grab a guy and drag him and then you might just have
to sprint.
But was we do that,
like you said,
we do that stuff at high noon cause cause like you said,
everyone wanted to be acclimated for the worst case scenario and that was
something we saw over and over again.
Even the,
by the way,
I remember you run in those,
I remember you run in Dean through that,
uh,
do that training.
It was brutal.
I was like that's rough.
That's rough thing.
A good training,
awesome training.
Prepare you for those worst case scenarios.
But we,
it was humbling and we'd see,
you know,
we'd have great team guys,
brothers who showed up,
you know,
in her body and want to go out on patrol with us guys who we knew were
incredibly fit,
great athletes,
kept himself in shape.
Um,
these certainly worth of guys that let themselves go and we take 'em out on a
patrol and like they'd be falling back.
You know,
they'd be having a hard time keeping up.
They'd have,
they had to learn that same lesson that I learned.
Uh,
and then you'd see him after getting after it,
right?
Like training and pushing the envelope.
And I think that was a lesson that we learned,
some great tactics for the marines and also got my hats off to those young
marines that were,
that were getting out there in the thick of it.
They taught me some,
some,
uh,
some great lessons there that enabled us to go forward and,
and,
uh,
really a push,
you know,
push the envelope going deep and areas that nobody could get into.
Um,
and setting up the sniper Overwatch is,
and help and protect it.
The soldiers and marines that were building those combat outposts.
Uh,
but we had to be physically fit and we had to carry on the,
the essential gear that we needed a new,
what's interesting,
I'm sitting over here cause we,
you know,
obviously we're in a business consulting business,
but same thing that we'll see with businesses when they want,
they want to do the same thing.
They want to build their infrastructure so much that they can handle any
scenario that's going to happen.
So they're going to hire three more people in case of this and the hire six more
people for that and they'll hire four more people for that,
for that contingency,
right?
It's like you saying,
well I might run out of magazines,
I'm going to put five more in my backpack and I might throw these four grenades
so I need three more months.
And next thing you know,
these companies,
they're so overburdened with,
with overhead and with cost structure that the same thing happens.
What happens is they lose their ability to maneuver.
And so it's the same thing.
You take that combat principle of carry what you need.
Think about it and don't carry too much.
And you'd apply that to the business world.
Hey,
if you don't need to bring that extra person on board and you can get away with
a contractor for a little while and you can pay somebody some overtime,
do that until you have to make that decision.
And you'll know.
So that's something you actually taught me,
uh,
in,
in Ramadi.
You know,
we,
uh,
you,
you can't,
you had been in Baghdad and had those good experiences of these capture kill
raids and,
and uh,
it,
it always seemed like we're,
we're going in this house,
we don't know what's in that house.
We know we believe a bad guy to be there and maybe has some people.
So,
so I'm going to put 25 assaulters in that house and you know,
I'm going to put as many people as I can.
And then you're like,
hey,
I don't think you need that many people.
And initially I was like,
that's crazy.
Why would I not want to take them all?
And then you recognize like 25 people in the house.
There's a lot more may him.
There's a lot more chaos.
There's people bumping each other and you're like,
yeah,
maybe,
maybe 14 guys is all I need.
You know,
for this particular target.
Guess what else?
When you're on this target,
where's the biggest threat?
The biggest threat actually oftentimes isn't in the building you're taking down.
Cause you're doing that aggressively.
You have a good force.
The harder threat to co,
you know where the threat is.
A building is,
you know,
480 square feet or 1,400 square feet.
You know how big that puts a,
it's a,
it's a finite area.
Whereas when you're in the street,
360 degrees,
that threats there.
So where do you actually need people to cover a threat that you don't know and
don't understand?
You need them in the streets.
That's where you need them.
And that's where we always went heavy on the streets and at the assault team is
a smaller package and plus it's very easy and very controlled.
To be able to say,
Jocko,
I need four more guys in here.
Boom,
you got them super is doing the opposite.
Hey,
send four guys out in the street.
We don't know where but send guys out.
It's,
it's totally,
it's much more hard.
It's much harder to do that because it's a much less controlled situation out in
the streets.
And I think for leaders,
that planning piece,
right?
To think about where is that contingency,
what,
what are the likely the tendencies that may happen.
So yeah,
keep that essential personnel,
essential resources,
uh,
and focus.
You can't plan for every contingency and if you do,
you're going to overwhelm your team.
Uh,
and,
and it's going to,
it's going to cause more problems trying to,
trying to solve every contingency then,
uh,
that it wouldn't otherwise.
Yeah.
All right.
That's good.
That's good stuff.
You know what,
I'm do go back to the book right now.
Here we go.
They were called legs or grunts
to carry something was to hump it as when Lieutenant Jimmy Cross humped his love
for Martha up the hills and through the swamps.
Okay.
Almost everyone.
Humped photographs in his wallet.
Lieutenant Cross carry two photographs of Marfa.
As a first lieutenant and platoon leader,
Jimmy Cross carried a compass map,
code books,
binoculars,
and a 45 caliber pistol that weighed 2.9 pounds fully loaded.
He carried a strobe light and the responsibility for the lives of his men
as an Rto.
Mitchell Sanders carried the PRC 25 radio,
a killer 26 pounds with its battery as a medic rat.
Kylie carried a canvas satchel filled with morphine and plasma and malaria
tablets and surgical tape and comic books and all the things a medic must carry,
including m and m's for a specialty bad wounds for a total weight of nearly 18
pounds
as a big man.
Therefore,
a machine gunner,
Henry [inaudible] Dobbins carried the [inaudible],
which weighed 20 pounds unloaded,
but which was almost always loaded.
In addition,
Dobbins carried between 10 15 pounds of ammunition draped in belts across his
chest and shoulders.
They all carried ghosts.
When dark came,
they would move out single file across the meadows and patties to their ambush
coordinates where they would quietly set up the claymores and lied down and
spend the night
waiting
in that section.
When I was reading that clearly this is very similar to the operations that you
conducted a tone of which was,
you know,
they're calling them ambushes here and we called them sniper Overwatch's but the
idea,
hmm.
You know,
the idea for those of what was happening is very,
very similar.
You know,
you guys are patrolling out to a location just like you talked about setting up
for remain over day or for the night.
Okay.
How did you feel like,
you know,
you kind of talked about it,
but did you feel like you were ready for that stuff and
you know,
a lot of times like you said,
we,
we were,
we trained to drive a lot and we ended up walking so much cause the IED threat,
how did you,
how did you manage that once you got on the ground?
Well,
I think,
thank God we had actually trained and,
and you know,
it's been a part of the seal teams is Vietnam,
you know,
going out in the southern California desert and training and you know,
land warfare,
you know,
is that that awesome block where you go out and learn how to patrol,
uh,
which we've talked or you know,
you talked a lot about the podcast and certainly we talk about with echelon
front and you know,
where it's man camp out in the southern California desert and this rugged
environment would just sharp rocks and,
and Yak this spines and rattlesnakes.
So,
so real quick,
everybody in the world,
when they hear the term southern California,
they think of Bay Watch,
right?
They think of Baywatch.
We talking about Baywatch.
So when you go east from the coast in southern California,
you enter a place places that have names like death valley,
right?
Those are the kinds of areas we're talking about.
We're not talking about,
so cow Baywatch,
we're talking about inland in the,
in the deserts,
the hard deserts of California.
And that's where it's one of the primary places where we trained for combat.
And it is,
I always used to say that our desert training facility is where men become frog
men,
even though there's no water out because we're men become frogman cause it will
test you no doubt.
And I,
you know,
thank God that we,
we get tested like that and that puts,
you know,
the,
that kind of training,
um,
is a,
is something that's kept seals a lab on the battlefield and enabled us to,
to accomplish them.
Some great things for a long time.
And I remember that first shakeout patrol,
it was a good one.
The land warfare instructors,
yet we're fired up and get out in the desert to train,
get our land warfare on,
dial it in,
uh,
our procedures and learn how to work together as a team and patrol and we show
up to the camp.
It was funny because generally,
I mean,
I'm not going to say that you have this immense trust with the cadre,
but like,
you know,
we're kind of friends with these guys.
We know him.
And so they did a really good job of,
of suckering us in on that,
on that first patrol,
because they said,
hey,
we're just gonna send you guys,
have a little shake out patrol tonight.
And so a shakeout patrol in the seal teams means you're gonna put your gear on,
you want to see how everything rides on your body.
You want to make sure that it's comfortable.
You want us to make sure that there's no tags that are wearing on you or
anything like that.
That's just a shakeup to go get your little hand signals,
make sure we're all good to go get to know each other a little bit.
It's just like a little,
it's basically like a little walk,
like,
like a little walk.
I mean,
they think it's probably going to take a shake out.
Patrol should probably take hour,
maybe two hours at the most.
We're just going to be,
you know,
kind of relaxed mode,
doing a little shake patrol.
And that was the setup.
And is it administrative?
Right?
So you're like,
hey,
let's work on this.
It's that.
So it's,
it's not like you're,
you're in the game acting like you're in enemy territory the whole time and
it's,
you know,
so you're kind of talking with instructors and figuring things out.
So,
yeah.
So they're like,
oh yeah,
just the land warfare cadre or like,
yeah,
just,
just to shake out patrol.
No big deal.
So we're just showing up,
you know,
no one's got there.
I know I didn't have my gear stitch.
I,
I grabbed some stuff that I'd had from advanced training,
uh,
what we call SQT seal qualification training from,
from like two years before that.
Um,
and,
uh,
I had these two canteens that had been filled with water,
um,
in that gear.
And I don't think I had empty that water in like two years.
So there's probably a little algae growth and some nastiness going on in these
kids,
deans.
So I just like,
don't uncle Oh,
shake out patrol,
you know,
it.
And then we were rushed because they were,
they were,
they were like,
hey,
we gotta get this going.
We gotta get this going.
So we,
we arrive,
you know,
guys are trying to get settled.
They're like,
Hey,
get out,
know,
get your gear on.
Let's get over there.
It's so,
so we throw our gear on and I throw on that gear,
those canteens and this two year old water in it and we're a,
and we're,
we go,
we'd take off on the patrol.
And what we didn't know was that,
uh,
this shake out patrol was a,
was a,
was a man test.
It was a man test and what a,
where are we like to use the seal teams called the mud suck,
which is basically a sucker punch,
right?
They,
they put together in patrol.
That was,
it took hours and hours,
took the whole night,
the whole,
the whole cycle of darkness the whole night.
And no one had several guys,
didn't have any water.
I remember,
I remember Ryan.
Joe had like no water at all.
And I remember him like,
you know,
just was like,
hey,
uh sir,
do you have,
do you have some water?
It actually came up the,
I came up to you I think,
right?
Because it's like you said,
no one had water.
And actually I had water.
I had water,
I was going on.
To me it was like shake out patrol.
Of course,
even though I was like,
oh,
it's kind of administrative.
Of course in my mind I'm like,
hey,
it's a shake on patrol,
but I'm doing everything the way I would do it normally because I'm super
hardcore.
So I got all my stuff the way it's supposed to.
And also I had the advantage of having done a lot of these trips in my time.
So for me,
I didn't,
it wasn't trying anything new.
It wasn't a shakeup.
Patrol from me was just a patrol.
But yeah,
I went and got good water,
my canteens,
my camel back,
and I was all good to go and I was ready for this.
And because discipline equals freedom,
you were,
uh,
you had the freedom to go out and execute with your water.
Meanwhile,
I'm carrying these canteens that I know of,
like I can do,
say she like your first sip,
you spit it out.
I actually,
I got so thirsty,
right,
that finally I was like,
I gotta I gotta drink something.
And,
uh,
so I,
I,
I pull one of these canteens out again,
you know,
it's just nasty.
I open it up.
I like smell.
It was like made,
it smells like it smells like a fish aquarium.
And I like just,
I,
but I'm at this point,
I'm desperate.
I'm desperate like two or three,
four hours into this thing,
everyone sweat.
So I was like,
I take a big sip of this thing and it just immediately projectile vomit data,
uh,
that stuff back up.
Um,
and uh,
I,
I think I gave one of those campaigns to,
to,
to write,
cause he's so desperate.
But I asked you for water,
how'd that work?
Can I ask you for what?
I was like,
Hey Jocko,
do you have any water?
And I was like,
yes.
That was like,
yes,
I do.
And you said,
kick guy,
can you,
he's,
your voice was scratchy,
but do the whole nine yards you?
Or did you like,
can you give some of that to Ryan?
He didn't bring any water.
And I said something along the lines of,
well,
first thing I said,
no,
you can't have any of my water.
If,
if you want water,
you must hump it in.
You don't,
I don't Hump in your water and I'm not humping in Ryan's water.
That doesn't work.
That's why you bring in your own water.
And then as I think I said,
like if he's going to die,
I will give you some water.
If he's not going to die,
you will get nothing.
And he got nothing and it just so everybody understands like it is.
It is pretty.
If you can't carry your own stuff in,
right,
it's,
it's pretty taboo to have to have to lick,
depend on somebody else.
No kidding.
At that point we didn't actually know,
I didn't know how long we were going to be in the field for.
I mean we,
they were keeping in the dark wood.
They didn't tell people and they did a really good job of,
they brought us into the hill,
into the hills of southern California where you're going to be going up and down
terrain and the terrain is uneven.
And they did this whole link up drill.
So it wasn't like we were just blindly walking.
It was link up from starting with swim pairs and then fire team link up and then
squad link up and then platoon link up and yeah,
so we,
the,
the future was very unknown at this time.
It's all,
I,
I wasn't,
you know,
thinking,
Hey,
I'll just give a bunch of my water away because yeah,
you give all your water,
you've got nothing,
and then you're struggling to keep up too.
So it's,
it's,
it was a bad situation and it was an Sasol.
I think I might just have like peaked a little bit at least getting in the zone
a little bit.
Definitely borderline.
But look,
I think the reality was,
uh,
you were helping reinforce the lesson that you gotta have your gear squared
away.
You gotta be right and you gotta be ready for contingency like that because that
happened all the time to us.
You know,
where we like,
hey,
this is going to be,
you know,
obviously we're in Ramadi and were like,
hey,
this will be a 24 hour operation.
Like,
no,
now it's a 48 hour operation.
Now it turns into a 72 hour operation.
We're going to,
we're going to stay here longer than we thought.
So you gotta have you gotta be squared away.
You gotta be thinking about that and you know,
thank God we had a such awesome,
amazing leaders like,
like Tonia,
fratty,
you know,
there's just been on this podcast and that people love and which is why we can
say his name because otherwise we'd name off all the other guys that were out
there.
Good.
You know,
the Lpo pose that getting after it,
the e five mafia in there running things.
So yeah,
it's a,
it's the whole crew and that was exactly and just leaders at every level that
we're stepping up,
leading their fire teams,
leading their squad.
Uh,
and I think that was it.
Thank God I appreciate it as,
as much as that sucked.
And as much as people were complaining about that at the time,
um,
those kinds of training scenarios where we didn't see it coming and it was a lot
harder than we thought it was going to be.
It got us ready,
you know,
to,
uh,
for those,
those long rates,
patrols and Ramadi.
And when we got there,
like you said,
we thought we all thought we're going to drive.
And they were like,
well,
we can't drive man.
That's the best way to get killed if you don't try to drive into some of these
areas.
So Park your vehicles and walk in on foot.
Uh,
and again,
we know we learn,
we only had to carry the essential stuff,
but we also knew we had to carry some fire power to,
cause one of the things that we did in Ramadi was,
you know,
I think oftentimes special operators can get a little spoiled where,
if you're going out on a mission and it's got some higher profile and you've
got,
you know,
you've got aircraft supporting you and,
and you know,
you're going to have all this,
uh,
you've got close air support set up where it's,
it's just dedicated to you,
you know.
And here we are,
we're,
you know,
we,
we had 40 seals and tasking at bruiser,
so I'm leading them 16 man seal platoon.
And maybe a couple of other augments,
um,
you know,
with seals and,
and our EOD bomb disposal technicians and Iraqi soldiers.
And we're just one tiny unit out of 5,600 troops,
marines and soldiers,
the First Brigade,
First Armored Division,
Brigade Combat Team.
So,
um,
there isn't dedicated aircraft to us.
You know,
there isn't a QRF that's a quick reaction force that's dedicated just to us to
come out.
Yeah.
Because on top of it,
you know,
we had our unit and just because you were out with your platoon in a firefight,
you were not the only game in town at that time.
There would be three or four other units somewhere else on the battlefield that
were in a firefight may be worse,
maybe not as bad,
but there was,
there was always someone that's calling the QRF or that needs air support.
So it was exactly like you're saying,
we,
we weren't at the top of some food chain.
We were just in the,
in the food chain and had to learn how to mitigate that stuff by,
so,
so you know,
that massive load out that you took and you were heavy.
You,
it's not like you said,
okay,
I'm not going to have to carry this stuff anymore.
You still had to to bring it w we had to make sure that,
uh,
that we carried our own firepower into those areas when in an era where we knew
that the tanks may have a hard time getting in there to us,
even if,
even if in the the emergency scenario,
and we didn't want to be overrun,
you know,
50 enemy fire trying to overrun our position.
And we only had,
you know,
eight or 10 or 12,
12 guys in this position with some Iraqi soldiers who were pretty much worthless
when it came to,
uh,
to beating back and enemy attack.
Uh,
like that.
So,
um,
and then,
and by the way,
there were many positions,
small positions,
some sniper size elements that were overrun.
And despite,
I know before we showed up,
there was an element that disappeared and they didn't,
they found their bodies months later.
But you know,
same thing,
it was a smaller element of,
I don't know,
it was five or six guys in a sniper type element.
They got overrun.
They didn't know.
No one knew what happened to them and it,
how it happened to large fortified positions as well.
If you remember some of the checkpoints that were well fortified and built up
and they got completely overrun by,
by,
by Moosh.
And so,
yes,
my driving a big thousand pound Vbi d truck bombing and their position horrible.
We had to carry all kinds of that,
that fire power with us.
We had to carry on our backs.
So the belt fed machine goes,
guys carrying those,
those,
uh,
the machine gets it.
We're going to beat back enemy attacks.
Um,
Carl Gustaf was,
was,
uh,
our shoulder fire writes a recoilless 84 millimeter recoilless rifle that we use
and it's heavy,
super heavy.
Um,
it's great against enemy tanks.
Uh,
the [inaudible] didn't have any tags,
so,
um,
it was probably a lot heavier than what we needed.
Uh,
our,
uh,
our leading petty officer would just man up BTF and carry that thing in.
Um,
and he figured out pretty quick though that I think the first time he tried to
carry it in and he's,
uh,
he,
they were on a long range foot patrol and,
and going into an area that was,
this was a ruler a little bit outside the city.
And so now,
you know,
we were used to patrol on the city streets in this rural area,
a Mc one that was kind of out east of,
of Ramadi.
Now you're talking about petroleum through farm fields and flooded,
flooded areas where you might be an ankle or knee deep mud.
It looked like Vietnam.
It looked like every,
every war movie that you see about Vietnam.
In fact,
we used to call it Vva Rom via Ram.
That's what we really call it.
And it was,
it was,
it was just like that.
I mean,
my first patrol that went on out there were literally waiting through irrigated
fields through mud.
And,
and,
and waiting through canals cause there's all these little canals are coming off
the river to irrigate the fields.
And,
and there were some marines support and us that we had,
we had a Huey helicopter and a Cobra gunship which are Vietnam error platforms.
Yes.
And I was like,
man am I am in Iraq right now,
our Vietnam,
this is great.
There was,
there were people out tilling the fields with like a,
like an ox.
I mean it looked like something straight out of it was actually crazy out there.
And if you want how much it looked like Vietnam,
it was nuts.
It was nuts.
And it was not anything that we'd expect expected to do,
certainly.
So we just had to prepare for that contingency and,
and uh,
and figure out a way to,
you know,
to operate in that environment.
Um,
and,
but,
but you know,
our Lpo is carrying that,
you know,
carrying that big man a rocket.
Uh,
but he recognized right away.
Like,
initially he tried to carry some rounds in his backpack and you know,
each of them,
I don't even know what this thing weighs,
but it's,
it's gotta be what it's gotta be.
I think the weapon itself probably weighs 25,
25 pounds and each of the rounds,
because you got to wait.
Towns are heavy willpower pounds.
Yeah.
Maybe 15 pounds.
I don't know.
But so when you put that thing,
when you load that thing,
uh,
initially carried in loaded and they'd put around his backpack and it just
weighted down.
He couldn't do it.
So,
uh,
you know,
it was a hard,
hard keeping up.
So recognize I'm going to carry it empty.
I'll carry it in my hand.
I'll put one round in my backpack that I can use and then we'll put a another.
I always carried around for it in my,
in my rucksack as well,
you know,
that I could hand off to those gunners if they needed it.
But that gave us some firepower to be able to,
to beat back in any of the attack and we had to carry that stuff in on herself.
So it just,
it's uh,
you know,
one or two guys that can man up and do that.
And our LPO was,
was the guy to BTF with that.
Yeah.
And you said if you need it and you needed a lot because,
um,
you know,
I don't know if you remember this,
but you guys shot the six month load out of Carl Gustaf rounds in about a week
and a half.
So,
and then we had to borrow a bunch from the rangers and we actually shot their
load out too.
So it was awesome.
We actually got the cool Air Bert first round from the ranch,
which was awesome.
Yeah,
those are,
those were effective.
What does that mean here?
Burst Airburst means that,
uh,
it explodes over the top of,
so that gets,
are shooting at you from a rooftop,
right?
Like,
and,
and they're hiding behind a wall.
Um,
you could like,
you could,
you can,
you can determine like how far they are and set a timer on there so it explodes
over the top of that.
Oh yeah.
So it's pretty devastating.
It's pretty awesome.
We like devastating.
Yeah.
D Two bridges or got after it with some Karl g routes.
Yeah,
this kind of advanced though,
you know like technology wise where you can set how far you want it to.
It is advanced and throws,
throws another kind of twist and do you know you've got to be,
yeah,
it's good to go.
I didn't know.
I didn't know it was like that.
Well,
they actually had an airburst rounds for a really long time.
We don't hear about them though.
You know what I mean?
I know it's a little advanced in the civilian sector I guess.
Man,
it's pretty dope though.
That's good stuff.
All right.
Hey,
I'm going to go back to the book here.
Taking turns.
They carried the big PRC 77 scrambler radio and interestingly if you remember
when Andy Stumpf was just on and we were talking about being new guys in the
seal teams in the 90s we were still carrying PRC 77
in our trading operations,
which is pretty crazy.
We carried it buds.
We did did it for our comp shots and bud taking turns.
They carried the big PRC 77 scrambler radio,
which weighed 30 pounds with its battery.
They shared the weight of memory.
They took up what others could no longer bear.
Often they carried each other the wounded or weak.
They carried infections.
They carried chess sets,
basketballs,
Vietnamese,
English dictionaries in Sydney is a frank bronze stars and Purple Hearts,
plastic cards and printed with the code of conduct.
They carry diseases among them,
malaria and dysentery.
They carry lice and ringworm and leeches that patty algae and various rots and
molds.
They carried the land itself.
Vietnam,
the place,
the soil,
a powdery orange,
red dust that covered their boots and fatigues and faces.
They carried the sky,
the whole atmosphere.
They carried it,
the humidity,
the monsoons,
the stink of fungus and decay.
All of it.
They carried gravity.
Okay,
what a great description coming.
That's just,
and that's why like I said,
even though this book is,
you know,
part fiction in in a blend of truth and fiction,
that clearly is written by someone that was on the ground in Vietnam and there's
a lot of similarities between that.
Okay.
Environment and the land itself and the atmosphere.
In Ramadi,
what do you think of when you think of the atmosphere and the land or in Ramadi?
Just listen to that again.
It just takes me right,
right back there.
Uh,
you know,
to,
oh.
So no one could have been able to write that unless they'd been there,
you know,
unless they've been a part of that.
Um,
and uh,
you know what that was like.
Yeah.
For us.
And the first thing I remember about about being rod is just the,
the stitch,
you know,
it was,
there's something,
there was always the stench of something burning,
always the something burning and whether it was civilians burning trash because
there's no trash pickup and this total war zone city and you see this giant
trash piles everywhere.
And so certainly there was a stitch of that garbage all the time.
Um,
and uh,
but so they'd be burning trash and a lot of the burning was a burning vehicle in
the street that got id.
You know,
that was an explosion that went off.
That was,
that was a building that was on fire because the tax hit it with a main gun
round.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
or,
or the bad guys at driven of truck bomb into position and just just smoke in the
air.
And uh,
I remember that that statute burning and I remember the stench of the trash,
the garbage,
uh,
and,
and sewage,
raw sewage,
that was always a,
a statue as well.
And uh,
I kind of takes me back there and the kind of haze in the air that you get,
that kind of Iraqi haze,
it's kind of like a,
the,
all those smells that you talk about,
it's kind of like war is hanging in the air cause it's fire and it's gunpowder
and it's trash and it's a,
it's like that smell is war in my mind.
If I smelled that smell,
I think we were at war right now
that sometimes if,
uh,
you know,
sometimes you'll smell a similar smell or things like that.
It was just kind of take me right back to,
to,
to be in that environment.
Um,
yeah,
those,
the,
the statute I think is,
is a of that.
But it was,
it was also a stench that we loved as well.
Cause you know,
this is what we dreamed about our whole life.
And I remember Tony and I talking about that,
you know,
just,
um,
this is where we want it to be.
Right.
I mean,
every people in t bruiser are,
our boys were ready to get after it and be a part of that.
And,
and uh,
you know,
where else would we want to want to be that in that it incredibly difficult
environment.
You know,
this most dangerous battlefield.
And uh,
we,
we wanted to be a part of that.
So is that,
it was,
it stopped,
but it was,
it was,
it was a good,
I remember the first stage,
first big operation,
we did an [inaudible] and I'm rolling in there and it's,
it's dark.
And we kind of turned miss bane corner.
And as soon as we turned this main corner of theirs,
there's tires in the street on fire.
And
you know,
so you,
I could smell it before,
but I was like,
what does that,
what am I smelling?
Burning Tires,
Bruce.
Sure enough we turned the corner and it screws up your night vision goggles
because now they're getting all blight out by the bright light.
And,
and then as the sun's coming up a little bit,
you see the dark smoke.
And I remember that to me.
I don't know why,
but that to me was the switch in my mind that cause cause there's,
that was the first cause of my first big operation.
That was the first thing that I said to myself.
Go though,
those are the bad guys though.
The bad guys did that.
They're here.
They're,
they were just there.
You know,
it was like my first moment of saying that.
And it's also very distracting and hard to see and all that other stuff.
And I remember when I was running training and we would do mount scenarios,
my,
one of my big things,
you know,
I say all right guys,
how many tires going to put out to burn?
And I remember one time someone was like,
you know,
we're not going to do the tires tonight.
And I said,
no,
we're doing the tires tonight.
Always set tires on fire,
let that be known because it screws things up.
And I think it was just my own personal desire to be taken back to that place.
Like you were just talking about.
Well I remember those mouth scenarios going out there with you.
You know you run in that trading when I was at,
you know when I was at op operations officer and executive officer at a seal
team and it took me right back there and to me the smell that,
you know,
the,
the statute would hear the,
the call to prayer,
you know,
comes out and you'd see the graffitied walls and it was,
it was so much like that and it was awesome.
It was awesome.
He has night vision on our,
in our,
when we really got after it with the Mount Training facility and really did
everything we could to simulate what the guys were going to experience.
Man,
you couldn't,
you couldn't tell.
Actually you could you,
if you,
if you got transplanted you wouldn't go.
Cause we did the,
even the cause in Ramadi,
all the,
the electrical wires were all knocked down.
So we'd string these crazy wires up just randomly in art in the streets to make
it look cause cause guess what you'd be running and to get caught up in this
wire and you've got to make sure it's not an Iud so you can't just pull it,
you know,
it's all these little things to simulate as best you can.
But thank God he didn't have the rivers of raw sewage running through the
streets.
Sometimes I want to,
our guys would slip and fall down into,
which was just horrible.
I had one of my first appointment,
this guy was walking and I don't know what this was,
but
we were just walking in.
All of a sudden he walked and he fell through.
I was like,
there was a hardened shell and he fell through this hardened shell right into a
sewage pit and
cause all the,
I don't know what the shell was made of,
but it was,
we know what was under it and it was nasty.
It was a big metal pipe across,
uh,
across you've ever,
we called it Shit Creek that was actually the official name on the map because
it was literally like a creek of raw sewage and there's a big metal pipe and we
often patrolled across this pipe.
Um,
you know,
it was the one where you didn't have to jump it,
you could actually just walk across.
Um,
and later actually some of the army,
I said burn the grass out there.
And there was,
there were ideas all around it.
We ain't even know were there when we first patrolled in.
Uh,
but when one guy was with us,
he slipped off the pipe and the fill into the fill into a shit creek,
which,
and now you know,
he's,
he's gotta be in that uniform for the next four.
It's only a 48 hour operation,
no shower,
no shower for a good 24 48 hours.
That's good jobs right there.
I think the one thing missing two from,
you know,
from,
uh,
that we couldn't recreate in that,
in that mountain area that you were running.
It was,
it was so awesome,
but the,
just the heat,
the heat was overwhelming.
And I think that's,
that's what really got guys,
even guys that were in really good shape,
who were,
you know,
great athletes.
If you weren't a climatized to that did,
did,
it just didn't matter until you really got to climatized.
Um,
it would crush you.
And I remember that going in,
you know,
even like I said,
at nighttime,
it's still like 95 degrees outside and,
and you know,
when the sun's coming up,
there'll be a little bit of breeze kind of early morning and you get a little
bit of coolness and we're talking to,
it's like high nineties.
Right?
But you know,
it's going to hit one 17,
you know,
for the high that day.
And you're sitting on the rooftop and,
and my,
my rucksack is still covered with tar where you know,
the,
the tar starts creeping out at the rooftop and just melting into your bag and
stick it onto your weapon and your gear
and your uniforms.
Now I sweat a lot.
Like I,
I'm a sweat.
I sweat a lot as a person.
I remember.
But I remember one time and it wasn't when we did cop falcon the first time,
but it wasn't when they had air conditioning in there yet.
It was like in one of those inter between ops and I was down there,
you guys went out,
you guys were working and I was in their cop falcon and,
and I had come down in a Bradley or in a Humvee,
Bradley's or hobby.
They're both hot but,
but then I got in the building and I was coordinating with,
you know,
the,
the company commander and I'm sitting there and now I'm not doing,
now I haven't been doing anything physical.
In fact,
I,
I think I was inside with,
with my gear off,
just with my body armor on.
But I'm just sitting there and,
and I'm sitting there like looking at a battle map and it's just me.
No one's with me.
I'm just looking at the battle of map.
I think I'm trying to drive talking to you.
You're probably heading out in the city and you're going somewhere and I'm
looking at where you are and there is a stream of sweat.
I'm not doing anything.
I'm just literally sitting looking at a map and there is a of sweat coming off
of my nose onto the,
onto the battle map.
And I thought to myself,
Bro,
it's hot.
It is hot here.
Well and you were in the shade then and no,
this was,
this was at night.
Oh you would at nighttime.
Like we came down at night.
You guys inserted it and I was just sitting there.
So I had been sitting there for it.
And that's one thing that I always know this is the hottest time of day in the
desert is when the sun goes down.
I don't know if this is a true physic thing.
If you're a scientist and you want to come back at me with the facts,
maybe I'm wrong,
but let me tell you what it feels like.
And I,
I say this,
the heat comes out of the ground,
so all that has been beaten down the ground all day.
The heat comes out of the ground and then the wind stops.
And so it's just,
that is the hottest time.
It's true here in the southern California desert.
And it was true when I Iraq that the hottest few hours was after the sun goes
down,
like the next two to three hours is the worst.
Absolutely brutal on on that,
that same operation.
I remember we were,
we were running out of water because we know we,
we were out,
we had moved out 300,
300 yards or so down the street and set up in that big Ford story apartment
building.
And uh,
we run out of water,
so we had to do,
so I remember we're doing a daytime,
I was like [inaudible] have a couple of guys.
We had a stretcher.
We have a foldable like Israelis stretcher that we,
we open it up and me and three other guys are sprinting down the street because
we know there's snipers out here.
I mean,
we're right in the,
you know,
we're outside the perimeter and we're running back to where you were at the Cop
Falcon and we loaded up a bunch of case of water and the Maoris and then we're
sprinting back.
And I remember getting back from that,
you know,
and that we did that at like,
it's probably like two o'clock in the afternoon and it's literally like 117
hundred 20 degrees.
And I was,
of course,
we had our gear on and we do,
we're doing this 300 yards spread,
carrying a stretcher that probably weighs like 150 pounds.
We can bring it up with water for like 20 guys.
And it was,
you know,
in food.
And uh,
it was,
I don't think I,
I mean I look like I just got out of the shower for sure.
Just sweating all your gear and a lot of our IPO,
you know,
there was the requirement you had to wear I pro uh,
eye protection.
So either like,
like ballistic glasses or a and r guys had been wearing previously was the
goggles that you wear to protect your eyes.
You couldn't wear it because if you had it on it would be completely fogged up
and you couldn't see 10 feet in front of you.
And it was like,
okay,
I can protect my eyes or I can like get shot and killed or trip over something
and not be able to get where I need to go.
And you yeah,
cause you'd be completely blinded by the,
uh,
by the,
the fog and nothing where we tried to get the high speed ones with like the
little,
what's about high tech?
Here's some high tech,
we've got these goggles that had little miniature fans in them to blow fresh air
in there.
They suck it all.
Everything sucks.
Nothing works.
I'm like windshield wipers.
That's what you needed it.
That was another little TB.
Tea Brews bruiser saying everything sucks.
Nothing works.
Because someone was saying like,
hey man,
hey,
you know this,
this thing's not working.
We'll get everything socks.
Nothing works.
Deal with it.
Oh,
everything sucks.
Nothing works.
Next.
We know that it's a given.
Everything sucks.
Nothing works.
BTF BTF BTF BTF and actually we talked about the heat,
but you know we didn't talk about is the damn moon dust because you know he's
talking about there.
They had orange,
red dust,
the moon,
Dustin Ramadi was nasty and gnarly and it was everywhere.
I remember specifically Corregidor was completely covered,
which was the,
the camp on the eastern side of Ramadi.
We're the first of the five oh six was there and then we had a detachment of
seals there and when you'd go over there,
it was just every step you took,
there was
even trails that were getting walked on all day to the head or or to the Chow
Hall.
You those trails that were walked on every single day,
every day.
It didn't matter.
Every time you took a step,
there's a little cloud burst of this moon dust,
this fine,
fine moon,
dust covered everything.
And it was all over the city too.
It was like talcum powder and it,
it,
it was,
you know,
those tanks would come in,
they crunch up the concrete.
So even if it was,
even if it hadn't been previously paved,
now you're going to,
you got,
you got sand,
you know,
dirt and,
and uh,
and it just,
I remember it getting an everything.
So we park our vehicles.
I remember particularly to combat books,
grant,
you know,
right in the heart of just south central [inaudible].
Um,
and it was patrolling out of there.
You were in like knee deep moon does.
So you know now and at one patrolling out into a sniper Overwatch position
moving at nighttime.
And not only is it dusty and getting all over stuff,
it gets into your weapons and,
and you know,
you have to constantly clean them.
And,
and,
uh,
but I remember we get to where we were going,
you know,
get an Overwatch position and you don't often have to take your boots off and
just dump out like a pound of sand of that moon dust that had gotten inside your
boots.
Got in through the little holes in your little Johnny's,
any holes on your jungle.
It was,
what is Moondust just,
it's a death that happened.
It's this fine,
fine,
fine.
It's like Lafe said,
it's like talcum,
but it's dirt.
It's some kind of fine,
fine sand again.
I'm sure there's some scientists that's going to say that what it specifically
is,
but as far as I'm concerned,
it's moon dust.
That's where it came from.
This is,
we're not talking about like on the beach in Hawaii,
right?
We're talking.
This is like if you,
you walked through this stuff,
it's all over you.
It gets everywhere.
There's literally walking through it and there's like a cloud of dust coming
behind you so far.
You would drive by when it vehicle would drive by your same thing.
It'd be she's a good GI UBS walking.
You're just breathing this moon Dustin in and it's,
it's you blow your nose and it's just like Brown.
It's the color of the moon dust where like when you
dirt bikes or something in it,
more of a dry area.
I mean obviously I'm sure it's way worse than you know when Ramadi,
but same thing,
when you breathe,
you're breathing in,
your profit's going to come out below your nose.
It's just that,
that's just how it is over there.
Dust everywhere.
I'm taking this back to the book.
They moved like murals by daylight.
They took sniper fire at night.
They were mortared,
but it was not battle.
It was just the endless March village to village without purpose.
Nothing won or lost.
They marched for the sake of the march.
They plotted along slowly dumb Lee leaning forward against the heat.
Unthinking,
all blood and bone.
Simple grunts soldiering with their legs,
toiling up the hills and down into the patties and to cross the rivers and up
and down again,
just humping one step and then the next and then another,
but no volition,
no will because it was automatic.
It was anatomy.
And the war was entirely a matter of posture and carriage.
The Hump was everything,
a kind of inertia,
a kind of emptiness,
Udonis of desire and intellect and conscious and hope and human sensibility.
Their principals were in their feet,
their calculations were biological.
They had no sense of strategy or mission.
They searched the villages without knowing what to look for,
not carrying,
kicking over jars of rice,
frisking children and old men blowing tunnels,
sometimes settings,
fires and sometimes not.
Then forming up and moving on to the next village than other villages where it
would always be the same.
They carried their own lives.
The pressures were in Norman.
Yes.
In the heat of early afternoon,
they would remove their helmets and flak jackets,
walking bear,
which was dangerous.
Yeah,
but which helped ease the strain.
Now that that section obviously paint something different than what we
experienced because,
and,
and I,
and you can see what he's talking about.
You know,
you've got soldiers that don't know what the mission is that don't understand
what the strategy is.
And you know,
there's all kinds of books about Vietnam and,
and at the highest,
you know,
we talk about sometimes how maybe we didn't do a good job of telling people what
the strategy was.
And,
but at the highest levels in the Vietnam war,
there's confusion on what the strategy is just so there's no way that some front
line understands why he's clear in this village and not that village or that
village and not this religion.
They just don't know.
So what does it become?
It becomes like they're just robots,
human robots moving forward.
And I think we were very fortunate to be in a situation where,
you know,
we had a better understanding and,
and,
and again we talk about this in the book,
we could have done a better job.
It should have done a better job of making sure that everybody understood more.
But
there was an understanding,
there was at a minimum,
everybody understood at a minimum the evil that was there,
the evil that was there in Ramadi,
in Iraq,
that was torturing people,
raping people,
killing people,
trying to enslave people.
Everybody understood that there was evil there.
And that's what we were fighting against,
trying to help this local populace who was completely at the mercy of this
insurgent group,
which by the way had no mercy.
So I think we had that benefit for us.
But one thing that is completely unchanged is this talk of this strain,
the strain that is put on the soldiers on the ground.
And when you think back to the strain that you felt that your men felt,
what do you think of w what do you think of when you think of the strain?
I can absolutely relate to that.
I mean it's,
it's the,
yeah,
it's something you and I talked about right when we got home,
when we got home,
it was,
you called it the burden,
right?
When we got,
we got home and
I didn't even recognize how powerful that was.
You know what I remember talking to you about it.
We were like,
we all of a sudden we could relax.
Like there weren't,
were people trying to kill us right there.
There were when we arrived back from that deployment to Ramadi and we're back in
San Diego and,
and you,
and just the recognition that it's not just from our personal,
like,
hey,
not people aren't trying to kill me,
but like I no longer carrying the burden of,
yeah.
The decisions that I make and people's lives are on the line,
right?
Like at this moment right now.
And I want to make sure that I've thought through all the contingencies,
you know,
are we ready,
for,
for the these worst case scenarios,
have,
we have,
we planned,
you'll have,
we rehearsed these things.
Have we tried,
have we thought that what the enemy might do,
how could they hit us where we hadn't even foreseen it?
You know,
that,
that burden that you just carried all the time.
And,
and for me,
you know,
Matt,
after,
after mark got killed and Ryan got wounded,
it was just,
um,
you know,
four months into our deployment,
it was just this recognition.
I'm like,
man,
where that can happen at any time.
And I knew it could happen anytime,
but prior to that,
and it wasn't that we got complacent or that,
but,
but it was,
we'd gotten away with this so many times that you all,
you,
you start to kind of see like maybe we can make it through this thing,
you know,
without losing people as,
as,
uh,
and just going out there and,
and you know,
as you've talked about,
you can just only get lucky so many times like with all that evil and all that
horribleness out there that,
uh,
that
it can happen anytime.
And that's the strain that I think that I certainly,
I felt that for other guys felt when you see that your,
your brothers killed or wounded,
uh,
when you've had close calls and you recognize like,
just how,
um,
yeah,
how close we are to death anytime,
anytime we're rolling out there that uh,
um,
that is a strain.
It is a strain on you and it's something that wears on you.
Um,
and I,
I think,
um,
okay.
For me,
it was just always,
always worried about like just the,
the,
and when you see the violence of it,
you know,
the,
the vehicle graveyard that we rolled out through every time we're driving out
the gate and just the,
the twisted hoax of metal that used to be a vehicle that carried men or women in
them,
uh,
you know,
and those were US troops that were either killed or horribly wounded that were
in that vehicle that were destroyed.
Or if you see it,
id go often,
there's a hundred foot fire ball in the air and just frag,
you know,
the,
the metal fragments raining down,
you know,
for hundreds of yards in all directions from something like that.
You're like,
just the power of that,
you know,
the,
the violence of machine gun fire that's coming in close to you.
And how I often describe it is just the,
you know,
I wrote about in the book the,
the biggest,
strongest guy you can imagine.
Just smashing the wall with a hammer next to you,
as hard as he can on the inches from your head.
And it's from your head.
Just throwing concrete fragments everywhere.
And there's,
um,
and,
and you know,
now it's seven to 800 rounds per minute of that,
of that coming in at you with a belt fed bell,
fette machine gun.
And maybe there's multiple,
once you've met you RPG rockets,
just this rocking explosion is rings your bell.
You know,
even if it's just on the wall outside,
you know,
if one of those things hits the window and,
and,
and detonates on the bars on the window,
it's gonna just frag everybody in the room,
it's going to be horribly wounded or killed.
So that,
that was a strain all the time.
And I think the difference for us though is the,
you know,
in,
in any,
you know,
there isn't,
there were some,
certainly some guys,
uh,
and you talked about leadership that we learned,
right?
Get the guys carrying those heavy machine guns,
the,
the belt fed machine guns and all the gear that with them.
And they're like,
man,
do I have to carry this thing?
You know,
as a leader,
we had to remind them why that was important.
You know,
because they get that love,
hate relationship.
The machine gunners,
they loved the shoot that machine gun and they're awesome at it.
They hate to carry the machine gun,
right?
It's uh,
it's that love hate relationship.
And so when they're going in on a foot patrol that's a,
you know,
a mile,
mile and a half full petroleum into a tough era and they're carrying all the
heavy weight,
they get focused on that.
So you've got,
you've got to help them recognize like this,
this is why you are such a critical part of the team and why we got to have
these machine guns.
Um,
so you got to do it,
you know,
as a leader of something we had to do all the time.
But I think for these guys in Vietnam,
they're,
you know,
they're driving or flying into an area of patrol and into an area that's the,
it seems like they're seeing,
they're seeing new terrain all the time.
You know,
for us in Ramadi,
it was this tiny city that was,
it's like what,
three by three miles across,
you're talking about just the,
the,
the central central Ramadi piece of it.
Very small and we're going into the same areas all the time.
You know,
J street,
the j block,
you know,
Papa 10,
um,
you know,
these areas that,
uh,
going down baseline road and you know,
to 20th street and these areas that we,
we got to know and we understood,
you know,
where the,
the,
uh,
the bad guys were operating out of and we'd been in so many of these buildings
and so on.
Then we had to have the,
we had to mix it up and not patrol down the same streets every time and try to
come in and do some misdirection stuff.
Uh,
but we got to know these areas.
Um,
and you know,
even though it was a small area,
you know,
in these tanks might be less than a mile away from you.
Maybe there have been a half mile down the road,
you know,
in that environment.
If there's,
if there's,
you know,
35 ideas that could destroy any one of which could destroy the tank between you
and them half a mile away,
they might as well be a hundred miles away.
It doesn't matter.
So,
you know,
we had to plan for those containers.
We had to be ready,
but that was a strain that I certainly remember well,
and,
and I,
I remember that conversation as I'm sure you do,
coming back and,
and,
and recognize them.
Like
wow,
I didn't even realize how heavy that strain was until we got back.
And it was,
it was,
it was lifted.
Yeah.
It didn't happen right away.
It happened like we were,
at least,
I feel like we were conditioned.
It would be,
it would be like going to a planet where there was much,
much higher gravity and you're,
you don't even realize how much more weight you're carrying.
And then when,
when we came home,
it wasn't like an instantly the gravity changed.
It was like,
it's slowly in one day.
For me,
it was about a month that I,
all of a sudden I woke up and instead of the first thought I had when I woke up
of like,
what's going to happen today?
What bad thing can happen today?
It was like,
oh,
I think the waves look good and I'm going surfing.
And did go from that thought process from like you said,
it's the horror of the,
of the imminent danger.
Because like,
like you said,
you can only get lucky so many times and you go out day after day after day,
and you got,
um,
watching guys all over my guys all over Ramadi.
There's no possible way that they can make it through today without taking a
casualty.
And then they,
and then they make it through that day.
I got five elements,
three elements,
five elements to elements all out on the battlefield at the same time.
There's no way they're going to make it through today without a casualty.
And they make it through today.
And guess what?
You wake up the next day and now you're carrying that day and today.
So you make it through that day.
Now you're carrying three days and that just built and built and built.
And every once in a while,
obviously we would take a casualty and maybe you get a little reset,
but you don't.
It's just there and they're a heavy all the time.
And what's really interesting about this is you might be thinking is leaf
explain this.
You explain,
you know those feelings.
And I was,
I'm talking about right now,
you might think that we were solid and worried and sweat and,
and panicking or,
but,
but I'm sitting here thinking about it.
We would,
and everybody in the,
in the task unit,
we were having fun.
We were laughing,
we would have conversations.
We make fun of each other.
We'd make fun of,
our friends would make fun of our boss.
We make fun of everybody.
We'd laugh,
we'd have a great time.
And the,
the,
the strain,
even though there's,
there's,
you know,
fun and good times on top of it,
that strain is absolutely there and it stays there the whole time.
And it just builds.
I think the big illustration for that to me was when an operation was going on,
right.
And vehicles were lined up,
like get,
you know,
the vehicles are lined up out on the,
we had this main street,
you know,
outside of,
uh,
the,
the Toc tactical operations center and you know,
where your office was.
And,
and uh,
I remember that,
that bond that we had an in tasking at bruiser,
you know,
so often you get one of the seals are doing their thing and you got to support
personnel that are running the radios and the CBS that run the cabin.
They just do different stuff and they don't,
you know,
what was so awesome about tasking at bruiser was that we line those trucks up
and we know we're going out,
we're going out at operation and,
and if you were,
weren't,
if you weren't coming on the op,
I know you would,
you would always be out there,
you know,
out there shaking everybody's hands and talking to them and it,
and not in a way of like,
you know,
not in a way that there was more bid.
Right.
But in a way of like,
just the respect and knowledge that
anytime we're going out like it at any one time,
there may be,
uh,
any of these guys that are rolling out may not be coming back from this.
They may be coming back in a body bag and,
uh,
and that we had to be ready for that at all the time because it was almost a
daily,
daily thing.
And I just not only,
you know,
for,
for you and the,
the support person of the comms guys,
you know,
our,
our radio when that were out there,
these aren't seals and there,
but they're out there getting the radios ready and helping us out.
And people just come,
you know,
uh,
our,
operations,
you know,
chief coming out there,
I remember all those guys just lined up,
shaking hands,
talking to people.
It was just that.
And for the few offsets,
you know,
that I didn't go on with another,
another,
uh,
if we had something else going on and another units going out with our guys on a
different operation,
I'm not a part of the same thing.
Like going out there talking to those guys,
shaking their hands and knowing that like they may not be coming back from that.
Um,
and I think that was the biggest,
that was the biggest to me,
like illustration of like that strain.
And again,
we laughed,
we joked it wasn't,
there was nothing more,
but we are telling jokes and laughing and kid each other.
Um,
but uh,
but that was really there.
And I remember we got relieved,
you know,
by the next seal team,
seal team five that came in.
Um,
and you know,
good,
good Bros of mine that I'd serve with that because I'd come from CLT five.
Um,
and uh,
knew those guys when they were going out to,
you know,
I knew what they were going out into,
and I just remember,
uh,
going out there for that goodbye to them and shaking their hands and talking to
him.
Dot.
Cause we knew exactly what they're going into and they're going to keep,
keep getting after it.
It was one of the,
I remember when those guys came in and I was doing like the turnover brief to
their whole troop and I was,
you know how to sign,
I put a slide up and it was going through this and that and the other thing and
I'm like,
okay,
you guys are going to take casualties and,
and
like I never thought in a million years that somebody would be briefing me,
hey you guys are going to take casualties when I'm like,
oh you guys might hate is dangerous and it looks like you guys are going to take
casualties.
That is what is going to happen.
And that might sound negative,
but that was the facts that it was 100% true that they were going to take
casualties.
And we knew it,
we knew it.
And that's what was so hard to shake their hand and tell him goodbye and good
luck and,
and watch them roll out for the first time alone without us and know that could
be tonight and
could be tonight.
Okay,
I'm going new.
Uh,
hit one hit another section right now.
This is talking about talking about the men again
going to the book
for the most part,
they carried themselves with poise,
a kind of dignity now and then however,
there were times of panic
when they squealed or wanted to squeal but couldn't when they twitched and made
moaning sounds and covered their heads and said dear Jesus and flopped around on
the earth and fired their weapons blindly and cringed and sobbed and begged for
the noise to stop and went wild and made stupid promises to themselves and to
God and to their mothers and fathers hoping not to die.
And back to what we were just talking about
to have guys,
and you know,
we,
we did a podcast about a guy named colonel to peak and his,
his book called Battle Studies.
And when he describes men who,
one of his key points.
Okay.
Is he saying that men are horrified and they're scared of death and that they
have this just incredible,
obviously this under underlying the will of self preservation,
right.
That's the,
that's the thing that fuels people and he just talks about this tiny percentage
of,
of men that will overcome that and there'll be brave
and to think that we were lucky enough to serve with guys in our task unit and
to see the next task unit to come in and to see the soldiers and see the marines
to overcome that strain on a daily basis.
Okay.
That is absolutely one of the most humbling things that I think I will ever
experience in my life.
Yeah.
That's what,
that's what courage is all about.
You know,
I think,
uh,
just to,
to see guys,
you know,
that are just in the thick of the fight with bullets missing their heads by
inches.
You know,
I remember,
uh,
our member on the rooftop of building 99,
right on 20th street in the war.
We were getting hammered.
I mean,
enemy rounds coming in by hundreds and hundreds of routes coming to shatter the
windows.
And I remember our,
our EOD bomb disposal technician,
awesome,
awesome guy.
He's,
he's a lean on the rooftop and there's armor piercing rounds coming through the
roof,
punching through concrete wall,
you know,
d that's just like three inches over his head and he's just laying there and,
and I remember crawling up there trying to figure out how is everybody okay?
And he's like looking at me like thumbs up laughing about it.
And I'm just the humor of those guys,
right?
Dealing with that.
Um,
and no one,
you know,
again,
that that could happen at any time,
but,
you know,
um,
just seeing the guys guys like Mark Lee or I just the most hilarious guy you
could imagine.
Just cracking jokes,
you know,
and sing in the,
the cheese ball,
eighties tunes,
you know,
I am the warrior and,
uh,
and the US laughing about it,
talking about that stuff and just,
just that's how they dealt with it,
you know,
and,
but it just tremendous courage and,
you know,
not just our seals,
not just guys that,
that we work with those,
those marines and the soldiers that we served
alongside and just watching those guys day in and day out,
you know,
um,
who often didn't have as much control over what they were doing is we did,
you know,
at down at the frontline level.
Um,
but just out there getting after it with a great attitude.
Uh,
and,
you know,
nope,
nobody's fearless,
right?
Nobody,
you know,
some people think,
oh,
that,
uh,
we,
you know,
we get that question all the time,
right?
From businesses like,
well,
it's,
you know,
it's more mortals are,
fearful,
but you guys are fearless.
Like,
no,
nobody's fearless.
Like you,
you recognize how mortal you are and that can happen anytime.
And yet you see these guys just just totally selfless.
You know,
courage would just incredible courage to overcome that and just amazing.
I mean that's,
that's really to me that is the,
that is the bright light,
you know,
that we brought back from,
from that conflict to see and witness that and just the tremendous human spirit
that could overcome anything.
Okay.
Indeed.
You're going to kind of wrap up this section right now with one last little
piece of the book here.
And this is one of the guys being lavender,
last name lavender.
He gets killed and the lieutenant takes the blame himself.
He feels that that blame
and part of it,
he kind of blames on his,
his thinking about his girl back home,
Martha.
And He's thinking he wasn't doing everything he could do and
what could he have done better and where did he let his guys down and what he
could do different from now on.
And I'm going to the book.
He loved her,
but he hated her.
No more fantasies.
He told himself hence forth when he thought about Martha.
It would be only to think that she belonged elsewhere.
He would shut down the daydreams.
This was not Mount Sebastian.
It was another world where there were no pretty poems or midterm exams.
A place where men died because of carelessness and grow stupidity.
Kiowa was right,
boom down and you were dead.
Never partly dead.
Okay.
Briefly in the rain,
Lieutenant Cross saw Martha's gray eyes gazing back at him.
He understood
it was very sad.
He thought the things men carried inside the things med did or felt they had to
do.
He almost nodded at her,
but he didn't.
Instead he went back to his maps.
He was now determined to perform his duties firmly and without negligence it
wouldn't help lavender.
He knew that,
but from this point on he would comport himself as an officer.
He would dispose of his good luck,
pebble swallow.
It may be or use Lli Strunk sling shot or just drop it along the trail.
On the march he would impose strict feel discipline.
He would be careful to send out flank security to prevent straggling,
are bunching up to keep his troops moving at the proper pace.
And at the proper interval,
he would insist on clean weapons.
He would confiscate the remainder of lavender's dope later in the day.
Perhaps he would call the men together and speak to them plainly.
He would accept the blame for what had happened at Ted lavender.
He would be a man about it.
He would look them in the eyes keeping his chin level and he would issue new sop
in a calm interpret in personal tone of voice,
a lieutenant's voice leaving no room for argument or discussion
commencing immediately.
He'd tell them they would no longer abandoned equipment along the route of
March.
They would police up their acts,
they would get their shit together and keep it together and maintain it neatly
and in good working order.
He would not tolerate laxity.
He would show strength distancing himself.
So he falls back on what we fall back on all the time on discipline,
on standard operating procedures,
on maintaining everything in good working order.
And one of the things that you can see here in people we get this too is you'd
think these guys from Vietnam,
of course they're going to be paying attention.
Of course they're going to keep their weapon.
Your weapon keeps you alive in a firefight.
Of course you're going to keep your weapons clean.
But he as the leader,
he has to lead.
And I think that's a common misconception.
And we do talk about it all the time.
And just one of the most frequent questions I get asked,
like,
well,
you know,
in the seal teams you've got everyone's motivated and everyone's focused and
it's a life or death,
you know,
so they're going to stay sharp and they're going to follow procedure no matter
what.
And you know,
my,
my team's not like that in the business world.
Or you know,
people I work with aren't like that.
And the best teams,
they only follow that,
right?
Because they've got leaders that are stepping up and making it happen.
And look,
we have some amazing people in the seal teams,
just like we have some amazing people in the military,
um,
in army and marine units and,
and other special operations units,
et Cetera.
But even with life or death on the line,
people get complacent.
People start letting the ball drop,
not cleaning their weapons and when they need to or are not following a
procedure or letting their guard down because well we've done this operation a
dozen times and nothing bad's happened so nothing bad's going to happen.
Right.
That's,
it's like this common human emotion that you just make these assumptions and so
the only way that units are going to stay focused and not have that happen it
when they've got good leaders,
they got a fire team leader in charge of his four guys is stepping up and making
sure that his guys were squared away and stay in focus.
They've got,
you know,
they've got a squad leader making sure that his squad is squared.
The LPO leading petty officer is out there making sure that guys are dialed or
not cutting corners.
I mean,
I always saw that with guys,
you know,
we've been in the sniper,
Overwatch positions,
you got like some of them had like one stairwell in and out and someone's going
to watch that stairwell.
Someone's got to have a weapon and looking down that stairwell for 72 hours.
And so hopefully we can rotate some guys out.
So it's not just the same guy,
but,
but even so if it's going to be several hours.
So you watched him down that stairwell and it's boring as hell,
right?
And guess what?
You're the only guy watching that stairwell and everyone else has got their
backs to you.
So if you're not doing your job,
you're going to be those people get shot in the back.
And yet if what happens,
hey,
I've been here,
I've been on the stairwell.
It looked,
man doesn't,
we've done this operation dozen times or we've been in this building multiple
times.
Nobody's ever come up the stairs.
I've been sitting here for hours on end like hasn't happened.
So you people will fall asleep.
People will stop paying attention.
And only if you've got good leaders who are going to go check on that guy and
make sure that he recognizes that,
listen,
everybody's dependent on you.
You know,
not only you're going to get killed if someone slips up the stairs,
but the guys,
people are gonna get shot in the back and they were dependent on you to have
their back.
And it requires those good leaders at every level of stepping up and going and
checking on that guy.
And if he is tired,
he can't stay awake,
rotating out,
put somebody else in there.
But it requires leadership at every level.
Um,
so even with life and death and a lot people get complacent and this really goes
to what you and I talk about all the time,
which is what does it really mean to take care of your people,
you know,
that year?
Well,
I want to be liked,
you know,
so I don't want to be a real hard ass and I don't want to,
I don't want to like,
um,
you know,
I don't want to push too hard in that direction.
Or like if they cut this corner,
maybe it's not that big of a deal.
Uh,
and,
and obviously you can go too far in that direction,
right?
But you become the slave driver.
But,
but are you really taking care of your people if you're allowing them to cut
some corners that they shouldn't be,
you know,
are to get complacent when they shouldn't be.
And the answer is no,
of course not.
You're setting them up for failure.
Um,
and so you as a leader have got to step up and a and make sure that your peer,
you know,
the peers around you,
if you're not in a leadership position,
um,
it certainly as a leader,
make sure that your team and those around you are towing the line and fall on
those standard operating procedures and,
and,
and achieve and that highest standard possible because that's what is going to
allow them to stay alive on the battlefield and ultimately accomplish the
mission and certainly dominate and win on their battlefield anywhere in business
in life.
Yeah,
you can definitely see that.
All the things that Lieutenant Cross rattles off that he's going to now start
imposing.
He's going to start taking care of.
He thought he was taking care of his men before by,
by letting them have dirty weapons and not hounding them about that by letting
them drop gear on the trail by not sending out flank security cause it's a pain
in the ass.
He thought he was taking care of his guys and he got one of his guys killed.
And that is exactly the point when you're taking care of your people,
that means you're taking care of them.
That means you're holding the line,
you're holding the discipline and you're making sure that they are
as safe as you can possibly make them while still accomplishing the mission.
Yeah,
and that is the,
that's pretty much what we had for this book by the way.
Again,
it's called Tim O'brien.
The name of the book is called the things they carried.
Definitely a,
a,
a solid read in and I would check it out and echo will have it up on the,
on the website.
And yeah,
I know for those of you that are going to come at me and say it was a fiction
book,
so now you're going to start submitting to me every fiction war book that's ever
been written.
I don't know.
There's some damn good ones out there and there's probably some I'm going to end
up doing.
But um,
yeah,
this is one of them that is,
and again,
it's,
it's fiction,
but clearly it's based on the experiences and it,
and,
and once again,
you can see that even though war evolves and war changes,
the fundamental,
the fundamentals of human nature in war don't really change.
I'm not into fiction books.
I don't remember the last time I read a fiction book.
I'm going to read that book because that immediately resonated with me and puts
me back in those,
just the sights and smells and then,
uh,
and the stuff that we carried and opens up.
So,
you know,
it's just,
uh,
I look,
I look forward to digging into it in some detail,
the good one.
And you know that that's a thing when,
when you are dealing with these books
and you start to really,
really listened to them and read them,
there's just,
there's always so much more than an
then you get out of it the first time you go through it.
So that's why for me,
you know,
reading it and then going through it again and then sitting here and reading it
and,
and now when I put the headphones on and read it,
it's it.
They definitely,
they definitely hit you and you get more out of them in my opinion.
No,
there's something magical about putting the headphones on,
you know,
cause you,
you had read a couple of those experts and we were talking about this over the
last couple of days and what the podcast is going to be bad and it did not.
It did not.
You know what's sitting here listening to you read it with the headphones on.
It's like takes me immediately back to Ramadi,
thinking about the stuff that we,
you know,
the things that we carried with us and the moon dust that we patrolled through
and those smells and statues and the heat.
And um,
frankly,
uh,
I'm,
I'm pretty eager to go back and get something right now.
I'm ready to make it happen.
He indeed,
and you know,
what we got to do is,
it's the same thing with,
with these other books with,
with our book and,
and I know,
you know,
we were kind of talking about this a little bit.
You know,
when you write a book,
you're confined in,
in some way to the structure of the book and to the length of the book and to
the balance of the book.
And so you can't just drill down on some facet.
That might be,
it might not be totally pertinent to that particular way and then it's laid out.
But what we're going to have to do is we're going to have to get the next time
you come on,
we gotta do,
we gotta do our own book.
We got to do extreme ownership at least get it through a few chapters because,
because we,
we know the authors,
you know,
and we know that there's so much back behind those that it would be awesome to
sit there and,
and kind of give a bunch of those,
you know,
a bunch of the backstory behind these things.
And I think next time we got to,
we got to make that happen.
Let's do it.
I like that idea.
There's a,
there's so much there and it is a,
even going back and reviewing the book,
you're thinking about these little things,
I'm like,
oh,
we should've said that obviously doesn't illustrate this,
you know,
the the point and we got to focus it.
But uh,
yeah,
there's a lot,
a lot behind that.
I mean,
I think about that blue on blue scenario,
you know,
it just opening tapper,
extreme ownership and what that was about it all that went into that.
Um,
and uh,
yeah,
be great to talk about that in some detail.
We'll have to get that next time.
Now.
Extreme ownership and name of the book.
Extreme ownership is also the name of something else that's about to happen.
May 4th and fifth the muster,
the extreme ownership monster leadership conference,
I guess is that appropriate to call it a leadership conference?
I'm not sure.
I guess we had to classify what it is then maybe we put in that category.
But to me the muster stands by itself,
you know,
and I think the definitions that you know that we utilize a gathering together,
a troops to prepare for war.
I guess that fits very probably so I,
I can't say I go into like big details about the monster,
but I,
I just mention it in case people are interested in getting
better,
especially from a leadership perspective and really from a
human
potential,
you know,
getting to where you think you can get getting beyond where you can think you
can get,
I don't talk too much these about whatever for,
so since you're here and you're sitting here,
what do you think?
What's the what,
what,
what did you,
what were like the highlights of the monster?
Cause if we just did the first one last year in October,
2017 I thought it was going to be cool.
2016 Oh sorry,
2016 I what did I say,
2017 oh yeah,
that hasn't happened yet.
I thought that the mustard would be cool.
You know what I mean?
I thought,
hey,
this is going to be cool.
Like it's gonna be cool.
We're going to meet a bunch of cool people and we're going to talk about all
this cool stuff and do our best to pass on information and give and receive
information and all that.
So I thought it was gonna be cool,
but it was a lot better than cool.
It was.
It was frigging awesome.
And what were like some highlights for you when you think about it?
What are you excited about for New York?
Well,
you know,
we talked to so many people all the time,
right?
And,
and,
and awesome leaders,
you know,
from colleagues that we work with and different organizations out there and,
and it's just loved bloodwork and these leaders love talking to them.
I think for the muster was there was just something magical about that.
You know,
I remember,
uh,
I,
we couldn't have even predicted that.
Right?
I think,
I think you just came up with a new tagline,
come to the muster.
It's magical.
Come up with a new word.
I'm going to take some shit for that.
Come to the,
and we're going to call it the magical muster.
Maybe we need to cut that.
They're going to be cut.
So what was,
what was magical about it?
Look for me,
what was it?
Here's,
here's,
here's what a coming off the stage where we're talking about,
you know,
we're leaving people with the idea of why,
they need to take advantage of every day,
the gift that's been given to them by those brave warriors that gave their lives
so that they have the ability to pursue that.
You know?
And uh,
I remember cutting off stage that you gave me,
you just came up,
gave me a big hug.
You're not a hugger.
I don't know.
People weren't often,
it actually not at to take down at all.
We'll call it.
I thought maybe something like that was coming.
I was getting,
I was getting ready.
you're getting ready to do as a sprawl,
but,
uh,
I remember that just,
just that emotion of like,
this was an amazing event.
It was an amazing event.
I think what made it amazing was the,
you know,
we were able to interact with so many people,
on,
on so many people that were in the game and had the same goals,
the same drive.
Exactly.
And from so many different walks of life.
You know,
we had some awesome,
we had some really high power,
you know,
senior executives from,
from some great companies,
uh,
to mid level managers and frontline leaders that are just aspiring to take on
greater ownership entrepreneurs,
you know,
the,
uh,
um,
military law enforcement,
firefighters,
paramedics,
I mean,
across the space and people that we couldn't even envision or imagine from,
you know,
from,
from a volunteer,
you know,
nonprofit organizations and things like that.
Um,
and interacting with so many different people that are eager to learn to
implement the,
the president was extremely honored to in the their lives.
That was awesome for me.
It was interesting to me.
Some I hadn't even thought about is the fact that,
um,
you,
after we spent folks,
so many people that come up to me and said,
you know,
it was,
it was worth the price of admission alone just to meet other participants here
and learn from them and learn from each other,
you know,
fellow troopers.
And,
uh,
and it was,
it was just,
it was awesome to see that.
So for me,
you know,
all the events,
we speak at events all the time and we,
and we speak at great events,
uh,
and we work with great leaders,
but it was the absolute best event of all time that I've ever been a part of the
best audience,
you know,
and I'm,
I'm so fired up to go back.
Uh,
and it's going to be,
it's going to be that much better in New York,
right?
Oh,
it's going to be,
there'll be a few of the same folks that are going to come in and attend that
were there in San Diego and there'll be a whole new group of people who couldn't
come it,
it'll be even bigger.
Um,
and it's going to be awesome.
One of the things that,
that was awesome for me,
and I know it was awesome for you too,
cause we talked about it,
but the interaction that we had with everybody,
right?
And,
and I remember when we were kind of setting and planning the event,
that was one of the things where,
you know,
we were talking about this,
we're going,
hey,
we do this and we can have this person we've had.
And finally I just was like,
hey bro,
you know what we need to do?
We need to just be there.
No backstage,
no curtain,
nothing.
We need to meet and interact and answer questions and get in the game with
everybody.
And that's exactly what we did.
Like,
for instance,
you know,
there's,
we do a section,
we'd be,
we'd be up talking for an hour answering questions for an hour and a half.
When we get done with that hour and a half,
we would just step forward to the stage and step down onto the floor and there'd
be people lined up to say,
Hey,
what about this?
you just said that and what do you think I should do here?
And it was like that for,
for two straight days and not just after the sessions,
but a morning workouts.
Right.
And we are r zero four 45 club pts that we're cranking out these awesome
workouts.
And,
and uh,
and we,
I mean,
all levels of athletes.
There's some really high end athletes,
black credible belts,
she jujitsu players to,
to the,
uh,
you know,
just,
just some folks who have just started training or just started hitting the gym
and the courage to about podcasts or whatnot.
Um,
and came out and participated in that.
And I walk into,
you know,
jogging over two or walking back from those,
the,
those workouts,
talking to those leaders and people talking about,
hey,
what would you do in this situation?
You know,
I,
I remember,
uh,
having those conversations with people and you're helping them apply that stuff.
We've heard through social media,
so many of those people,
like some of those specific conversations like,
I can't believe how good this word,
here's what's going on.
I'm not,
I'm now able to,
I just got a promotion,
you know,
based on this that,
those cat,
that kind of feedback we always talk about,
right.
There's only two measures that matter,
effective and ineffective.
And how do you measure that?
It's whether the team is,
is accomplishing the mission.
You're effective.
If you're not accomplishing mission,
it doesn't matter how hard you work and you're not effective.
And for us that measure effectiveness is that people are actually going out and
kicking ass in their world and they're getting promoted.
They're accomplished in their mission.
They're building
a better team,
they're building better relationships with their boss,
you know,
with their peers,
with the sub contractor they work for,
with,
you know,
and,
uh,
they're,
they're being more engaged members of their community,
you know,
a better parent,
a better coach,
a better team member,
uh,
across all walks of life.
And I think that's really our measure of effectiveness.
Um,
and,
uh,
it was,
it's just awesome to see so many folks,
uh,
doing extraordinary things that were part of that,
the,
the muster.
Um,
and so looking forward to that May 4th and fifth in New York.
It's going to be awesome and it's gotta be exactly what you described.
We're going to,
we're going to keep that no matter how long we do this or how big the musters
get,
I never want to never want it to be a,
to lose that of,
of me and you staying engaged,
you know,
with participants not hiding behind the curtain somewhere in the green room,
but be and out fraud,
talking to people,
talking with leaders,
uh,
and helping them apply this stuff to get better at what they do.
This ain't the wizard of Oz.
We ain't going to be hiding behind the curtain.
And you know,
and you talk about
measures of success,
effective,
ineffective.
Well for me,
like the biggest reward from doing the monster,
it's,
it's similar to what we do with our,
with our business of helping businesses.
And it's always great to get that feedback.
But to get a mass scale of,
you know,
three or 400 people and get that feedback about the promotions,
the advancements,
the,
the goals achieve the fitness goals,
achieved,
the relationship goals to get that feedback has just been,
it's been awesome.
So like you said,
we look forward to seeing you there and you know,
actually speaking of the muster,
you're going to see life.
Yeah,
you're going to see me.
Of course you're going to see JP and Dave,
Dave Burke,
JP Denelle,
they're going to be there.
You're also going to see Echo Charles.
He's going to be there fully,
fully,
and kind of cruising too.
But he's going to be not fully cruising hard
so you can get to meet,
oh,
most people want to meet echo the most.
He's like the bass player in the band that like,
no,
you know there's the lead guitarist
and then there's the lead vocalist who is out front with the weird pants on.
But everyone looks at the basis in the back that's hammering down the tracks,
laying it down,
Echo Charles cruising,
you're going to get to meet him.
So that was amazing to me.
Actually the number of people lined up to take pictures with you and talk to it
to you as I was.
I was getting jealous.
It was like,
that was awesome.
Funny.
They don't ask me like real questions though.
It's more like on a social level,
which I liked that you want to keep it that way.
Easy questions.
You got to share leadership question.
You can go to lay if you can go to me,
if you want to do some socializing,
you know like getting that Echo Charles line going shake his hand.
You want to get an echo Charles line one.
One thing about the buster in New York in particular is,
uh,
you know,
like anything
in New York City got limited space and,
uh,
we,
we sold a lot of tickets to that thing already.
If you want to be there for four,
it May 4th and fifth get your tickets now because I think we're going to sell
this thing out.
And uh,
I think that's,
that's highly likely.
So those may not be there.
I would,
I would get those things purchased asap.
Um,
if you,
if you want to be a part of that,
do it.
Big Part that I noticed from the last muster is the,
Pete,
you mentioned this before where people,
they'll come in,
they'll learn all this cool stuff and you know,
likeminded people.
Um,
but they become like real good friends,
you know,
so like,
uh,
like that night when we had a [inaudible] training that night,
you could tell I thought that,
oh,
these guys came,
they all came together.
Yeah.
No,
they didn't come.
They go there,
they just became friends and now they're cruising as friends now.
And there's people,
you know,
doing things now.
Yeah,
we've got podcasts.
Yup.
Radians and in radio.
And also,
um,
Debbie,
Debbie and Sonya and Sonya.
Yeah,
they got a podcast going.
There's someone else.
Anyways,
so there's people that are,
that's the Wa Athena's podcast.
You've got the trooper podcast,
trooper,
trooper project modern if modern Athena's.
So there's things that are coming out.
Those are,
those are people that just met,
they weren't friends rolling into the buster.
They form relationships and now they're,
I'll just crushing things.
And that's how,
you know how like,
I mean,
Jujitsu does this a lot where you come in and you're like by yourself and then
after awhile,
Hey,
this guy likes digits to this guy likes to get to,
oh wait,
but wait,
hey,
you watched,
I dunno.
You know,
same,
the same show in slowly like Hawaii,
five o
slowly you start to gravitate towards these people.
But this,
in this kind of situation,
everyone's kind of like,
um,
like they're trying to get better,
you know,
better at this.
And it's,
so,
it's real similar life life in general.
So it's almost like a double gravitation effect.
You know where people,
like that's a scientific thing too,
by the way.
Some of them that you know don't know about the double gravitation effect with
the muster double grab gravitation effect,
easy moral effect across bro.
And it's funny cause you see it,
you see like everyone's all talking.
You know,
like if I step back,
I see you in life talking,
you can kind of tell like all you guys have known each other for a long time.
That's kind of what you see.
But then you realize,
oh they haven't known each other for a long time.
It's just pure double,
double grab had gravitation.
Okay.
I think some of that crossover too is,
you know,
when you,
when you realized that,
you know,
a police officer who's sitting next to you has some of the same challenge that
you have as a,
as a,
as a a,
a small business,
you know,
entrepreneur who has a certain problems as this guy who's the CEO of a big
company who has the same problems as this person who's in a start up.
So yeah,
who have,
by the way,
the same problems that Lafe and I saw and experienced on the battlefield and
their solution.
This is the thing,
you know those problems,
there are solutions to them.
Yeah,
they're,
they're out there.
This isn't,
this isn't magic.
As a matter of fact,
I know only will bust you down here,
but there ain't no magic.
There's knowledge to begin.
It's like Jujitsu,
right?
Do Jitsu isn't about magic.
There's no magic to Jesus.
Sometimes I do say magic.
It's a magical,
magical.
You do say it's a super power.
It's a super power.
And speaking of Jiu Jitsu,
what we're going to be trading.
So that's right.
That's right.
Friday evening we're going to be getting home.
Boom.
So if you come to the monster,
[inaudible] going to go Nogi for travel purposes.
Is that cool?
Yeah.
Okay.
So we'll go plan the Nogi Situation Plus Echo.
Like do you like Nogi better?
Oh,
it goes in phases.
It's only only so you can where you're a trooper,
you're trooper barracks.
Yeah,
sure.
Acquired.
Yeah.
Hash Hash.
Goguardian.
Yeah,
for sure.
So that is going to happen.
Echo.
Like I said,
back to my point,
Echo Charles will be there and come and see him.
And in the meantime Echo,
if somebody doesn't want to support this podcast,
can you let us know how to do it?
Yemen,
there's a few ways,
but I recommend supporting yourself.
We talked about being prepared,
right Leif Babin.
Um,
so good way to prepare is to train and with training comes help,
which is supplementation.
I was one of these guys who didn't,
who wasn't into supplements ever.
Like,
oh,
that's like,
it's fake.
I don't need it,
don't need it.
And really it's kind of true.
You kind of don't need it.
So I thought,
but if you get the right kind of like,
okay,
so you,
you know,
we talk about Krill oil,
supplements do matter.
So I'm going to talk about,
so,
so awesome.
Were you there when I rolled the other down?
When's the last time I saw you?
A couple of days ago,
I dunno.
Yeah.
Anyway,
I went in there like training with Chris Ruiz and he's,
he,
I saw you guys rolling.
Yes.
So I was there that day.
So we fished by the way.
Yeah.
And he goes hard.
Black belt goes hard.
Yeah.
And I think I did the rounds with him.
Fish.
Yeah.
Why do we call them soap fish?
Cause he's hard to get ahold of fish covered in soap.
You can't hold onto him.
Yeah.
He's like,
it's hard.
Slick and wirey greasy with a black belt and has the back.
Yeah.
It's one thing to be like a,
you know,
in untrained soap fish,
which can be hard enough,
by the way.
Anyway,
the point is,
I go with him,
I did three rounds with him,
you know,
and a few more rounds with other people.
And you know that feeling when you do a work on,
you're like,
oh,
I feel like,
I feel like the workouts not done.
I don't feel like as not like exhausted as I need to be after workout like this.
Yeah.
So I kind of had that feeling where I'm like,
okay,
I need to do it.
It was like,
who can I go with like a hard,
you know,
I need to go like another round.
Right.
And I remember they took the shoon tech.
You kind of forget about it cause I took,
I don't mean this in a bad way.
I don't,
yeah,
I don't mean this as a back handed.
There's going to be bad comment.
That's true.
But for everyone that doesn't quite know,
I don't normally see you as a guy that's going,
I need to get one more route.
A lot of times you're like,
good.
You know what that was actually not right.
Oh,
you're talking about the old me.
Okay.
Yeah.
Is it a praises?
This is free.
Shroom tech.
This is the bow with that pretty shroom tech free metcon.
Metcon.
Yeah.
So no,
that's not me.
You know,
I like that.
That is to your full credit.
Yeah.
You are different now.
Not just because of your skill level.
And you did it too,
but also because of your,
your metcon,
your endurance and all that.
You've definitely,
you,
you used to be done.
Yeah.
So,
and I and I talked about this before or that's a good point though,
because one kind of plays off the other,
especially if you don't like being tired.
So if you get tired early,
you're like,
you're going to do less and you're going to try less things.
You're going to,
you know,
because you're kind of fighting that fight as well,
you know?
So when that tiredness goes away and you know how to deal with being tired and
you're like,
okay,
now I'm kind of free to try this.
If it fails,
I can try it again.
I can not,
you know,
if you're,
if you're not in good shape or if you,
if you buckled to being tired,
it's like you only have a few bullets in the clip and once you're done and
you're kind of like,
oh my guns worse than worthless.
No,
no.
The gun looks good from lifting weights and all this stuff,
but it's done after a few bullets.
But you load up the bullets and lists bullets,
right.
You can go shoot targets here anyway.
Well that's how it is.
I will get you since I gave you a a a negative on the old you.
I'll say that new you got some,
you got some goods and if you got that Jujitsu yeah.
Which is way better than it used to be.
Yeah.
Even even the old Echo Charles,
so wouldn't know when we were rolling back in the day with Terry,
our uh,
our mutual friend cake nuts and I hear you.
Are you always it?
He'd go another route in particular for us that was when he is,
our skill level was far below his,
oh,
he likes those around me.
Smashing you.
And keep in mind,
in my defense,
this is Jocko z evaluation than me when he's like,
you're done.
Well Yeah,
when you're rolling with Jacqueline,
you're kind of done,
you know.
But it's not like I was just this sack of potatoes that was just done.
It wasn't like that.
With the white belts,
you have our full of round.
That's what I'm hearing is the standard that comes out of jockeys is very high.
Understatement.
Not that he's wrong.
Listen,
I mean he's,
he's just full of compliments all the time.
Thank you.
This,
I was like,
Hey,
can I say something like this?
You know,
I think it was like something positive about life.
And he's like,
yeah,
you did say that.
And I remember it.
Cause it's like don't one of the four compliments you give you the last 12
years.
I was like,
oh,
that's cool.
Don't happen often.
Got To know them when they,
the it,
that is true.
And it does help.
And not in just that way though.
Not In just the way like,
oh I can,
I'm,
I'm in better shape.
And that's good.
That's true.
But you just,
you can do Jujitsu now without that added enemy in there.
So you're like free to do more Jujitsu,
Jujitsu.
So to sum up the last 12 minutes of conversation,
what you're saying is yes,
on a.com/jocko.
Yeah.
You know,
I got into the story.
It was a good one in my opinion.
Um,
yeah,
no,
that day,
that's how I felt.
I felt like my work
done.
I was actually thinking the same thing because the other thing about Chris,
Chris soap fish is he moves a la La is a mover and when you move,
even if the guy's lighter than you,
you have to move with me or you're,
or you're going to get,
you're going to get caught.
And so you had to move,
you couldn't stop moving and he's gonna move all the time on you.
And that's why I was really impressed
with the fact that I've trained you so well.
I was impressed with how you kept bringing,
you know,
kept you wanting to do another round.
I could see it so good on it.
And I did take an metcon.
The thing is,
you forget,
I took it like,
like an hour before I even,
uh,
well I guess it was about an hour before it actually was rolling,
but it was like maybe half hour for I left.
I kind of forgot.
I'll tell you in this whole idea of shroom tech and what's the other one?
Performance total strength or it's like a or the strawberry banana that,
so if that's considered cheating that I've been changing a lot lately because
I'm rolling in man.
A lot of times I've already worked out in the day,
I've been up all day.
I went sir,
I've done a bunch of stuff so it's not like I'm rolling in to the gym or to
train the Jujitsu being all fresh.
I haven't been getting a massage all day.
No,
I've been back to grinding it out all day.
And so sometimes I need to get on soil rich and so going to call it good.
This is really why I say it's cheating because I'm always saying it while I'm
looking at you and it's cheating if it's like me against you,
who's,
you know,
who's the better warrior kind of thing and so all but you're on shroom tech.
Okay.
So you have a little help then still let you know.
But no,
if you're training and you want to learn Jujitsu or you want to,
you know,
push performance so you,
cause that's how you get gains.
You recover from exercise and you want to push the exercise and you want to in
Jujitsu situation where you want to train,
be able to train longer without,
you know,
the burden of this fatigue where you might have to quit at a certain time or
whatever.
Don't have to quit.
No.
Well,
you know what I mean?
You don't have to quit.
It is helpful.
This shroom tech is at some point when he get Rhabdo and you start pissing,
you got take some recovery.
All right,
this is my nonverbal signal for let's move to the next side and when I do this,
yeah,
no,
but there's still a lot to be said though.
That's the thing.
See,
and I think that's really the value of this whole thing is that this needs to be
talked about.
If I knew this,
like back in the,
you know
that guy that you were talking about,
that echo that you were talking about,
if I knew this kind of stuff,
yeah,
I would have spent very little time at [inaudible].
Do you hold that against me?
Because I could have told you about this stuff earlier.
No,
I don't,
man.
You know,
that's life.
Maybe I was afraid to anyway.
No,
I wasn't late.
I don't know if you're unsure the shroom tech or whatever.
Krill oil.
That's a big one.
I haven't tried shrimp shy,
but uh,
I just got a new order of acryloid actually from audit.
Just pull that I got.
I got some strong bone as well.
Yeah,
well that's good.
those are good because they keep you in like you can.
Yeah,
I do like super deep squats and I had knee surgery full on ACL,
like all this stuff.
Deep,
deep squats all the way.
No problem,
no factor.
Krill oil,
just boom.
Taking it through.
Nonetheless,
if you guys like these types of supplements,
go to [inaudible] dot com slash Josh if you want 10% off,
you add slash Jocko,
boom.
Get Yourself,
keep yourself in the game.
Also,
good way to support Amazon.
If you shop Amazon,
click through our website,
Jocko,
podcast.com this little Amazon banner there on the site.
It's actually in the menu to now you just,
you know,
in the top navigation menu is what you call it.
Click on there before you do your shopping,
whatever you're buying,
whether it be these books or whatever,
you know,
do it like that.
You can support small,
teeny,
tiny action,
great support.
Boom.
Another way of course,
is to subscribe.
If you're on iTunes or any of these other podcasting platforms,
whatever they may be,
stitcher,
Google,
play,
all these ones.
There's other ones too,
but I'm just saying some subscribe.
That's the point.
You know,
um,
even though you probably have already,
so
also youtube videos,
more videos.
I think I'm going to release one tomorrow.
Oh,
corn,
little fun one by tomorrow or you mean tomorrow from today?
Yeah.
So it already been released.
Maybe I might not blow unpredictable.
You know,
we call that variable reward system that I'm delivering right now anyway.
Um,
youtube channel.
We have some videos on there.
Uh,
if you'd like the video version of the podcast or you like these other like
chunks of lessons or whatever that Taco talks about,
um,
subscribe.
You'll get a little notification when they come up.
Want to upload them if you want it,
if you want.
Yeah,
of course.
People don't,
don't like to get notified.
Yeah.
I actually stopped to notify because sometimes such a long period of time comes
between when a video comes out from you.
Yeah.
It was like that before.
I know,
man,
that was,
those were hard times,
you know,
it's not like there's no way I could ever possibly know unless I got that little
notification that says Jocko podcasts is just uploaded a video and I'm rejoice.
Yeah.
You kind forget about it really.
But yeah,
no I did turn off the notifications for that one because it'll go off right when
I finish uploading.
So I already know when they're uploaded.
Seems Sane.
I do see what you're saying.
Sensitive to sounds cool.
Um,
the not the last way,
but another way is if you wear tee shirts and you want to represent who doesn't
wear tee shirts,
not me.
I want to teach.
That's it.
That's my whole uniform t shirt.
Boom.
Um,
but yeah,
if you like t shirts you want to represent in this way.
Boom.
Jocko podcast shirts,
multiple types of shirts,
a rash guards as well for the Nogi situation.
Jujitsu or like anything where you need range of motion,
like running,
cycling,
crossfit,
all this stuff anyway,
they're good.
May or may not give you 19% improvement in all performance.
Why are you saying may not?
I think that's like,
um,
the scientifically literate way to put it.
Nobody,
there's,
it's,
it's actually will because there's no one that said,
hey,
I didn't get the 19% out of this gig.
Yeah.
I think,
yeah,
actually Jaeger,
right.
There you go.
Boom.
18.7%.
Yeah.
You know,
you get one of these slackers that maybe,
you know,
I don't know if you have the rash guard,
you're probably not a slacker.
So I guess that's invalid as well.
Um,
but yeah.
Anyway,
Jocko,
store.com that's where he can get all the,
you know,
rash guards and cool shirts.
I think they're cool.
We made a,
we went through great lengths to get the good shirts,
like good quality.
One guy emailed me,
actually not one guy does.
I had got another recent email said it's my favorite shirt to wear because of
how it fits and it cause it's good,
you know,
it's not like a give away free shirt.
You get,
you know when you go to the soccer game and wherever you go,
you know they're cool.
Check them out if you like them,
support that way and get one and represent and psychological warfare.
Okay,
so I'm going to go into psychological warfare.
If you don't know psychological warfare,
if you're at a moment of weakness in your diet,
workout,
uh,
waking up in the morning,
he needed a little boost,
a little like someone there to sort of gently spot you,
help you through these moments of weakness.
You go on Itunes,
maybe Amazon music,
wherever you can buy mp3s,
get psychological warfare,
Jocko Willink,
little tracks.
He can listen.
You can put it as your alarm if you want or just listen to the whatever track
you need and he'll get you through it.
I'm telling you,
here's the thing.
So yes,
day before yesterday,
not yesterday.
Yes,
the day before yesterday I was about to work out,
felt like working out,
rested,
boom,
you know,
took my pre workout stuff ready.
I was like,
all right,
I'm going to die.
All listen to psychological warfare at my moment of strength.
Has this ever been tried before?
I don't know.
That's the thing.
That's what I was thinking at the time,
Bro.
It's kind of like abuse.
You know how like,
you know how like you're,
you drink coffee or something.
He's like,
fuck,
I'm kinda tired.
I'm gonna drink some coffee.
And when you're not tying to drink it,
it's like I'm buzzing off the,
and you have that
good feeling now.
You're like double coffeed up,
ready to get after it.
That's how you feel.
It's like I'm abusing the psychological work only for moments of weakness,
for moments of triumph is what it is.
That's it.
Not even so even if you're feeling weak and you want a moment of triumph,
that's what it is.
It's what,
how was the workout is the question.
Workout was dope.
Of course.
It was double check me out,
Bro.
Pumps still on anyway.
Good.
Um,
you know while you're clicking through Amazon,
by the way,
you can get on amazon.com you can get Jocko white tea.
Now there's other reports have come in and this report,
what I found interesting because this is a side effect apparently of the t of
the tea and that is any,
this could be a positive side effect or it could be a negative side effect
depending on who you are.
But one guy reported that he drank some tea at night and he had 1.5 inches of
beard growth overnight.
So if you want that to prison it could be positive,
could be negative.
And also we had a police officer out there and,
and again this is just,
I'm just giving some new,
some new testament testimonies that have come in.
This one,
um,
one police officer,
he's shooting the El Presidente Day drove,
which is a drill where you have two targets and you sh two rounds in each target
and you'd do a reload and his time has decreased,
which is an improvement,
right?
So he stopped being able to do this faster,
31% which I think is really good.
Especially numbers.
Yep.
This is a critical situation,
right?
You've got two bad guys and then you got to do a reload.
You might want to have some Jocko white tea that's almost double the 19% yeah,
it's good.
And Yeah,
and the thing is that I want to make sure everybody understands is that this
isn't like conjecture and some pseudo science that I'm talking about here.
This is 147% factual,
so everyone should know that.
So order the tea that Jack White Tea.
Also you can order a new book,
which is called way of the warrior kid.
And I got asked why I wrote this the other day and one of the things that
propelled me to write this book was I was looking for book when my son was a
little younger.
I was looking for a buck for a boy to read.
It's got a book.
And so,
you know,
I wanted him to read kind of a right kind of a book about getting after it,
right?
So I went out and I looked through a couple of books and I finally found this
pirate book and I got cool pirate book.
I didn't pay too much attention.
I didn't like look through it because it's a pirate book,
right?
Pirates are swords,
ships taking over,
right.
Storming vessels.
All good.
See,
so go into the book,
I break,
bring it home to my son,
we start reading the book and um,
they were weak.
And so now I'm like trying to get my son,
you know,
partner and opening in game and he's reading about weak pirates.
They weren't,
they didn't even attack anybody can do it.
So I realized that there's a dearth of books for children,
not just boys,
but boys and girls that will show someone how to get after it at a young age.
Right.
Which,
and you can start getting after it at birth.
By the way,
there's no reason to wait.
There's no legal minimum age.
You have to be 18.
Oh,
can I see your kid again after it license?
You're get after it.
Id Card.
No,
you can start getting at after at birth.
So that's one of the reasons that I wrote a book about a kid who's not going to
be a pansy and not going to be wimpy.
He actually is in the beginning,
he's feeling pretty weak.
You know how many pull ups you can do?
How many zero pull ups?
It's not good.
You know,
you know what he's,
you know,
you know well,
he knows his times tables,
how well he doesn't know him,
but know his times tables.
That's weak,
I guess.
What can he swim?
No,
can't swim.
And last thing,
is he getting picked on?
Yeah.
Kenny Williamson,
Jenny Williamson,
the bully.
He's all up on him,
pushing him around.
He can't stand up to him.
Doesn't know what to do.
So is that a good way to go through life?
I don't know.
You tell me.
Zero poems.
Do you want to be able to do zero pulps echo?
No.
No,
not good.
You gotta be able to do some pull ups.
So
that's why I wrote the book so that the kid out there,
they can't do any pull ups.
Maybe he's getting picked on.
Maybe,
maybe he can't swim,
but maybe there's some other thing in his life that he,
we all got issues.
You know,
we all got something we got to overcome.
Right?
We all got feared.
Overcome.
Guess what?
We talk about fear in the book cause everyone's life was talking about today.
We all got afraid.
How you can overcome that.
It's true.
Well luckily for mark in the book,
his uncle Jake shows up,
uncle Jake was in the seal teams and he's got some lessons to teach to young
mark and that's what he does.
So you can preorder it right now way of the warrior kid.
And you know,
we gotta make some tee shirts on that one.
Yeah.
Oh,
kids tee shirts.
Yeah.
The few parts that you did tell me it's even you explaining like that's a good
little explanation of it and it's good.
But the little parts that you were telling me were,
were kind of impressive.
Like there is,
that's kind of advanced for a kid's book even,
you know,
in a good way.
Meaning like it's not,
you know,
there's certain obvious things that you,
you,
you know you're going to find any kid's book,
right?
Even with stories like this,
it's like,
okay,
I know the narrative,
I get it.
We'd hand it has to be that way to,
you know,
to teach the lesson effect of all this stuff.
But the little hints of complexity there were impressive.
I got to say the other thing that is,
or even when I read it right now,
just finished finalists edits and you're like,
there's so much in there that's actually from the podcast,
but it's for a kid,
it's putting the kids language,
uncle Jake's breaking it down real.
So that's why,
that's why I don't care who you are.
You,
you walked her broken down.
That's a law combat and the book extreme ownership written by Leif Babin and
myself.
Got to keep things simple.
So it's in a simple way.
So that's where the warrior kid,
and also by the way just released another book.
It's called discipline equals freedom field manual.
And this is the,
this is the ebook that I talked about here in a long time ago.
I'm gonna write an Ebook,
right?
Well,
it turned into a real book and it's broken into two parts.
One part is called FOBTs.
Okay.
The other part is called actions.
These are actually my thoughts and my actions.
So what are thoughts?
Well,
what I think about what's going on and what I think about when you run up
against weakness,
what do you think those were?
The thoughts and the actions is,
okay,
how do you act?
Which means workouts are in there,
which means talks about martial arts,
talks about what I eat,
how I sleep.
Okay.
And that kind of stuff.
So
preorder it,
check it out.
Okay.
And it will help them logistically when the book comes out.
Because see the publishers,
they don't understand what we're doing here.
They don't know what we're doing here.
They don't know what I'm talking about.
We are not talking about you.
I'm not talking about we,
I'm talking about,
Oh yeah,
yeah.
They understand what we're doing here.
They understand that there's troopers.
I want to get after it.
Nope.
So when they don't understand that,
they're like,
okay,
well,
you know,
I guess we'll print,
I don't know.
I guess we'll print 400 copies of this and that way,
you know,
again,
somebody can buy yet.
Right.
But they don't know.
Emilia is good.
They don't know what they're talking about.
Yeah.
So
preorder so that they understand what we are doing here.
Maybe we'll get some of them in the game actually.
Okay.
So that's that.
And you don't,
speaking of books,
leaf hours,
talk about a little book called extreme ownership.
What are you hearing from the field on extreme ownership right now?
The book that we wrote,
I'm a,
I'm hearing a lot from the field on a straight line or show me what,
what's,
what's awesome?
The about extreme ownership is just continues to resonate with people,
you know,
and uh,
even,
you know,
we're,
we're over a year and a half out of publication now.
Um,
and that this thing continues to be in the top.
You're hotter and 50 or 200 on,
on Amazon.
Uh,
and so much of that as word of mouth driven,
you know,
that people are buying that for their team,
and holding,
Whoa,
wait a minute,
what will did it help with that big ad that we put in the New York Times?
Did that help sell it?
Oh wait,
no,
we didn't do that.
Oh,
maybe it's the TV spots that we did.
Oh No,
we didn't do that either.
So word of mouth.
It is.
Exactly.
And I,
you know,
for that,
that's the real testament I think for,
you know,
uh,
for me that,
that we wrote a book as resin with leaders that's helping them get better,
to lead better teams,
for people to be better
teammates and employ these concepts and extreme ownership,
you know,
and when we see them,
uh,
you know,
the,
uh,
the fire service training that's going on,
you know,
and,
and fight firefighters are using that as their,
their training manual conducting these,
these training.
We see police,
uh,
police units doing it.
We see,
uh,
businesses,
you know,
and some of them bring us in and have training someone,
they're holding their own training and they're buying that book and they're,
uh,
they're,
they're learning out of it.
Uh,
I was working with the business just a,
just a couple of weeks back where they,
you know,
each,
each group in this,
the leadership team was assigned to study a chapter and talk about how,
what in that chapter applies to them.
And they're,
they're,
they're learning out of that.
And it's inspiring to see that stuff because not only is it,
is it,
you know,
does it say,
Hey,
we wrote a book as having some impact.
But when you see the things that they're doing,
when they're implement extreme ownership,
when they're using cover move and they're not focused on themselves but about
the mission and working together as a team and use in decent vice commander,
you know,
explaining the why to their teams,
um,
and,
and the results are amazing,
you know,
see that happen.
And,
uh,
and that's really,
you know,
that's really what it's all about for us I think is seeing that kind of impact.
So,
uh,
it's been awesome to see that.
Um,
and uh,
looking forward for that to continue to,
to grow and expand its reach across the globe.
You know,
we,
we talk about in the book we talk about working with Iraqi soldiers and one of
the hardest things,
obviously even if you took a great soldier but they don't speak the language you
speak and you have a language barrier,
that's a real problem.
So a lot of times in these teams,
what the book gives them,
what the extreme ownership gives them,
it gives them a,
a language,
a common language to talk about the issues that the leadership problems that
they're having.
They can identify it because how can you fight an enemy that you can identify?
So if,
you know,
if you don't know that,
hey,
our decentralized command is weak,
and if you don't know what that is and you can't identify it,
how can you fix it?
If you got a cover move to solve problems and work together.
But you don't know what that looks like or you don't even know what to call it.
How are you going to get it solved?
So that's one of the things that I noticed when we show up at a company that
already is,
is using it and have read it.
They're immediately saying,
you know,
hey,
this is this,
this situation we got.
We got these divisions over here in this division over here and we're not
covering moving for each other.
We got to identify and you go,
okay,
so they've already got a grip on it.
When people that we go and talk to,
they haven't read the book yet,
they can't even really identify what's wrong.
They just don't see it.
They don't have the,
the ability,
it's like not having night vision.
They just,
they just don't see it.
So the book,
when you get that book out there to everyone on her team and all of a sudden
they all have that common language,
they all can identify targets.
They know what the bad guys look like and they know how to fix it.
And that's,
that's what I noticed.
That's awesome.
About when we work with these companies and they're,
and they're in the game big time.
And then the,
the muster May 4th and fifth New York City.
Go to extreme ownership.com sign up.
Now,
like I said before,
I think this thing is probably going to sell out.
So if you want tickets,
if you want to be there,
if you want to be a part of this bad
ass event that we just,
we were talking about just this amazing group of people,
of leaders and aspiring leaders to get in the game.
Sign up now,
extreme ownership.com I will not get you doing a speech for the record.
Just so you know,
everyone echo doesn't think he's going to give a speech.
We think he probably should.
How about a side speech?
Most speech all the time and site speed echo was,
equity is a very laid back,
you know,
the,
the good island add to when we put them up on stage for the muster.
He was not happy about that
and that was just to say thanks.
Yeah,
you went in your shell.
Nah,
man,
I got it.
You're welcome.
Hey,
you know,
on with the show.
So you know what we were talking about,
you got to focus on your weaknesses,
right?
So I think you need to present at least for a couple of hours on the stage.
So I got to talk about this one thing because it just happened again.
So the echoes got this thing where he goes into this alternate voice at the end
of some sentences.
And I noticed in one of the last podcast that I actually started doing it too.
So everyone has been saying,
Hey Jocko,
would have you gotten from echo?
Well I think the one thing that I could say I definitely got from echo is doing
this thing right here because that's what he did and he just did it.
He just did it.
So pay attention to that.
I don't know.
I knew what I call that.
I'm going to call that the echo voice escalation.
So you just talking normal and then all of a sudden you go into that echo voice
actually escalation so that you've got your own thing.
Now it's effective.
It's effective.
See how you do that.
That one,
that one a before the monster,
until the muster.
If you want to,
uh,
give us feedbacks or comments or whatever you want to continue this
conversation,
you,
you can actually find us not hard to find and find us all of the interwebs,
uh,
Twitter,
Instagram,
me,
and of course,
of course you want to find us on that pace.
[inaudible] Paul,
how are we going to be that I one Lafe is at Leif Babin Echo is at Echo Charles
and I am at Jocko Willink.
Echo,
do you have anything else to add right now?
Oh Man.
Oh yeah.
Actually I do.
And I heard you mentioned this before,
where you're talking about in Ramadi,
where you know,
the sun comes up and you see,
you hear the call to prayer.
I know what that is,
but what,
what did,
like,
what does that sound like?
What does the call to prayer,
you know,
what is it a person like on a,
it is a person.
It's a person or on loudspeaker,
right?
So each mosque has a minaret,
which is a tower,
and they generally have a loudspeaker.
And,
uh,
and so you've got to,
I forget what the title is.
And then,
um,
in the Islamic world,
there's that,
there's a specific title for the prayer call or that's going to get up and sing,
sing this prayer.
Um,
but yeah,
you just hear these speakers going off all over the city and it's like a chant
to kind of,
did they sing sing?
It's a song.
It's a,
so it's so many that,
you know,
when you hear that,
like the sea,
so there'll be one early in the morning before the sun comes up and we had to be
in place,
you know,
you're going,
you're going into enemy territory.
You had to be in the building,
locked out,
ready to go,
because as soon as the call to prayer goes down,
you know that the city is going to start awakening,
drink,
we're going to start off,
you know,
coming out of their houses and cars starting up and people moving around and,
and the sun's going to come up pretty soon.
Um,
and so,
yeah,
there's,
there's five of those throughout the day.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
that would be the,
you have to hear that that morning called the prayer was like we're going to get
some can the enemy,
the enemy in Ramadi for the most part didn't operate at nighttime because we had
all the advantages of night vision and everything else.
So they operated during the day.
So the indicator that the day was starting as the first morning call to prayer
and when you'd hear it,
man,
that's so crazy how it's like,
it's like this official beginning of the day,
you know,
call that's like the official commencement of the day.
Isn't that crazy?
I guess you would think it's crazy.
I mean we have that individually,
you know,
your alarm clock or your whatever.
But like for everybody,
that's one of the things that makes it so,
so crazy is that it's,
it is the whole city every day,
you know,
cause like one,
actually this was funny,
at one point they said,
hey,
you weren't allowed then the would they say we weren't allowed to go within a
block of,
of,
of a mosque or something like that.
And there's so many mosques in Ramadi.
We just showed them a map and we're like,
okay,
so you don't want us to do anything.
Cause if we can't go within two blocks of a mosque or whatever,
the rule that they tried to throw at us,
you know,
I said,
so you don't want us to do anything else on this deployment because here's a
mosque,
here's a mosque,
here's a mosque.
And by the way,
Intel says this mosque is okay.
Local mosque until says this one's bad,
this one's bad,
this one's good.
So we had,
you know,
different,
um,
you know,
because just because someone's,
the mosque,
some of the,
some of the neighbors are saying,
oh great,
it's called a pair of,
we're ready to start a beautiful day.
It was just some of the people,
the smaller group of people were saying,
Oh,
here's the call to prayer.
Let's go and attack Americans and,
and torture the local populace.
So,
and unfortunately because the mosque were protected and we had to get massive
approvals all the way up to like the highest levels to be able to enter,
enter the mosque.
Uh,
the bad guys knew that and they'd use those mosques to,
to stage a tax out of,
um,
you know,
and they'd,
they'd stockpile weapons and ammunition and stuff there.
So the bad guys figure it out.
It was,
uh,
it was not good.
Crazy,
man.
It's crazy.
The little detail,
Phil.
You know what I mean?
That,
I mean,
I always hear it from like you guys,
just a little detail stuff that you don't necessarily think about.
You only think about,
oh yeah,
the,
the gun fights and all this stuff,
but just those little details kind of makes it real,
man.
That's crazy.
Any other questions?
Echo Charles or comments?
No,
sorry.
Very good to see life again.
That's it.
Good.
Blake,
you got
anything else,
brother?
Yeah,
just great to be back on here with you guys again.
You know,
it's,
it's awesome.
Uh,
uh,
thinking back to the podcast 11,
you know,
I was the first guest,
uh,
and just getting this thing up and running,
you know,
and,
and to see the reach that it's,
uh,
that it's hat and as,
as the expansion and,
uh,
you know,
and where we're sitting today versus where it was then,
um,
you know,
the third time I'm back on,
it's pretty,
pretty awesome.
Pretty awesome to see that.
And I've so many people,
I'm going to sit in Jujitsu classes before someone hears me talk and w or you
leaf that.
Exactly.
I guess,
yeah,
the raspy voices.
It has given me a way,
but they're like,
I started training Jujitsu cause the Jocko podcast and I've had that happen
multiple times.
Um,
you know,
uh,
or they're in Jujitsu class or meeting someone at,
you know,
uh,
randomly in an airport or those kinds of things.
And,
uh,
it's just awesome.
It's awesome to see troopers all over the world,
uh,
you know,
all over the,
all over the place,
getting after it,
uh,
you know,
through and loyal listeners,
Jocko podcast and passing it on to others.
I,
uh,
echo asked me that because we get a lot of people that on social media,
they say,
Hey,
I just enlisted in the army.
I just listened to Marine Corps.
I'd go to Ocs,
a lot of people,
you know,
thanks for pushing me that way or whatever.
And Echo says,
you know,
like,
Hey,
do you think,
how many people do you think have actually joined the military because of the
podcast?
And I said,
you know,
I don't know what that number looks like,
but there's the amount of people that have started Jujitsu because of the
podcast is a big number.
It's a big number,
which is awesome because obviously you had us do Jitsu was really good.
I think the number of people join the military,
it's probably substantial as well.
In fact,
I was just talking to a young lady last night at the event we were speaking to
it,
um,
who came up to me and said,
hey,
I'm thinking about joining the navy.
And uh,
you know,
he'd said she just started listening to Jocko podcasts.
I think those are very much related.
I told her to go buy a copy of extreme ownership and uh,
you know,
to uh,
uh,
to learn from that and take ownership of everything in the world she was going
to do well.
So she was,
uh,
she was an EMT and a whatever.
You a navy corpsman.
So I think so many people from all walks of life influence for good by the Jocko
Buck.
Yes,
definitely.
Definitely.
Definitely awesome for us to be a part of it and get all that feedback all the
time.
And,
and of course there's no coincidence to the fact that you were the first guest
on here,
obviously.
I just did an echo escalation.
That was,
that was good.
Would
you have an influence in the world?
I hope you,
I hope there's not someone out there that doesn't like it and blames you and
then it goes on a crazy like stalker mission to eliminate you from the world.
Luckily he's pretty good at Jujitsu,
so I need to take care of him.
And he's got a lot of knives and hatchets so nice.
Any other closers?
Yeah.
You know what?
I was just thinking we were having that conversation yesterday,
you know,
and uh,
uh,
as a dad of young kids,
you know,
I've got a,
I've got a toddler and a baby.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
I know that Echo,
you've got young kids as well.
Um,
and um,
you know,
just thinking about it can be all you parents out there know what I'm talking
about.
Right.
He can be exhausting.
You know,
we'd gone through a time,
it's winter time.
He got kids who've got colds and they're sick and they're waking up multiple
times a night cutting into my,
my four 45 club workouts,
you know.
Um,
and it's,
it's easy to like,
it's easy.
You know,
when my,
my little baby girl crawls around on the floor,
she just tries to eat everything,
you know,
picks up the choking hazards and,
and,
and shoves him around and you got to keep an eye on him.
Could constantly,
you know,
and my son is just a wild man.
He's just,
he'll,
he'll just,
no fear of anything.
It's just,
I'm learning that he's just like me and I realize what my parents actually put
up with,
but he takes off running for the most dangerous thing within a mile radius.
And,
and he just like,
without looking back and without heating any warning or command to stop for me
whatsoever.
So,
so it's,
it is full time and I'm in the game all the time.
And it can be exhausting.
It can be.
Um,
it's something that,
uh,
you can think,
oh man,
I just can't wait till they get a little bit older and I don't have to,
you know,
I can tell him to stop or he knows not to run to the street or my daughter's not
choking on something,
something she,
you know,
and,
uh,
and the reality is,
you know,
just being out here read Jocko and seeing his kids,
and your oldest daughter's about to graduate now from,
from high school,
which is amazing to me because when I left,
you know,
San Diego here,
uh,
you're,
you're kids.
They were kids.
They were little,
you know,
and watch them grow up into teenagers now.
And you know,
when we first met,
we started working with the potassium,
the bruises.
They were really little,
you know,
uh,
your youngest hadn't even been born and you're still on.
It was just,
uh,
I mean just a baby,
two or three years old.
And so I just read,
I realize it doesn't seem like I left the navy that long ago,
you know,
it,
it'll be six years this summer.
Um,
and I realized that time has flown by like that.
It has just gone by like that.
And,
uh,
and so seeing that,
seeing your kids,
now I,
I got to take a step back,
the detachment that we always talk about,
right?
To be able to see with a bigger perspective of think
these moments,
right?
They dare.
Awesome.
And yeah,
I got to relish every nanosecond of them because my kids are gonna grow up and
they're going to be teenagers and they're going to graduate high school and
they're going to go off.
Uh,
and I got arrested,
you know,
for me and my wife.
Um,
we got to cherish those moments.
And people tell you that,
you know,
but you,
you still don't even like embrace it.
You know,
you still like,
Oh,
if I can just get to this level,
he's all worried about the diaper,
dirty diaper.
Exactly.
You know,
and uh,
or,
or you know,
my kid just went through my drawer and threw everything out and not going to
clean that up and we're trying to get out the door.
So I think for me it's a great recognition of like that those moments are
fleeting,
they're precious and a,
you got to enjoy every second of that.
So for you parents out there listening to this,
if you're in that boat,
w w with,
with me,
detach,
take a step back.
Think about how wonderful those moments are.
Um,
and uh,
and just,
just relish,
relish every moment.
And,
uh,
don't let yourself get flustered.
Don't let yourself get overwhelmed.
Um,
if your kids getting up at four 30 in the morning,
maybe it's time to back it up to a zero 300 club.
But uh,
embrace every,
every second of that as,
as a parent and a,
a cherish those moments because those are the most important things of all.
I'll give you a,
you all give a small tip that helped me with that.
You know,
when like certain things get overwhelming you,
you're trying to do this and they're crying and then the other one's doing
something and you're like,
you kind of want to yell at them,
be like,
Hey,
I need a minute or something.
But they're like,
kids are like a minute,
but what does that even mean?
Kind of thing.
They don't know.
So the tip there is anytime you feel it bubbling up,
like you're getting frustrated,
understand that you're at that moment and making it about yourself and it's not
about yourself.
You know,
it's about the weather.
You can look at it in a minute.
I'm going to make it about the mission or I'm going to make it about these kids.
Make it about something other than yourself and you won't be frustrated anymore.
I'm telling you anytime,
anytime you're like,
oh,
I've been up all night,
this baby's been crying to what?
You're just making it about yourself right now.
Oh,
he,
you,
Oh,
oh,
you poor parent.
You know.
Meanwhile,
everyone,
you know,
many parents have been through the exact same thing.
You're making it about yourself right now.
You're feeling sorry or whatever.
You know,
just don't make it about yourself and know that that's what you're doing.
If you feel that and then it solved.
That's exactly right.
Exactly right.
Check the ego essentially.
Yeah.
It's about them.
They should.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's not about you right now.
That's a good one.
Yeah.
That's great.
Great Advice.
Lafe and uh,
haven't seen my kids grow up and see I'm about to leave the nest as they say.
Yeah.
Embrace that whole time and thanks obviously for common on again,
I'm sure this won't be the last time and we'll,
we'll do it again
and everyone else out there that's listening.
Thank you all.
Especially especially in the military personnel across the globe right now.
By the way,
they're not getting to enjoy those moments with their family.
They're out there in harm's way,
standing the watch for us.
So thank you to all of you,
to the police and law enforcement.
Stay proactive and aggressive in your fight against crime and stay safe out in
the streets.
And thank you all for keeping our streets safe and the firefighters and the MTS.
And again,
who we call and we thank only when we need you.
Thanks for being there,
waiting to help us when we need it.
And to the rest of you out there doing what you're doing
as you go out there and do it.
Don't do it easy.
Don't take it easy.
And if someone says to you,
take it easy,
tell him no.
Tell him you aren't going to take it easy.
Tell him you're going to go hard,
as hard as you can tell him,
you're going to push and grind and fight and work as hard as you can until you
have nothing left.
And then turn around and walk away from that person and go do just that and do
it hard.
So until next time,
this is late,
an echo and Jocko
out.